foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
returning to the program Mike Lindell
CEO and inventor of my pillow what
what would you like me to say David
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
what's so hard to understand
[Music]
they can pull these names it's just like
every state every state has people that
voted that don't live in the state hold
it David you're doing the population of
Wisconsin I have a moral compass who
million you can get them I did I got
requests out to every single these are
right on the voter rolls David you're
not listening you're not
[Music]
get rid of my espresso machine the
voting machine David everything that can
be packed you got you know credit cards
companies can hack businesses act gas
companies act who did this attack who
did this Cyber attack that's all I'm
about we can't have computers running
our election Mike you've mentioned so
much let me just make one comment here
nope nope nope melt them down and turn
them into prison bars
[Music]
when you have a computer you can change
one number you can do anything you hack
in and you can expect Millions where if
you had to do the same thing with paper
you'd have to have a hold of all of
people you asked me the dumb question
about getting rid of machines if you
want to be a humorous interview get rid
of my espresso machine give me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you should have one of my pillows too
laughs
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
and showers
[Music]
some bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with trumpet
and toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
the United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms I'm worried about
my espresso machine
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
Lane
they're like
um
just exploded I'm trying for getting rid
of the machine felting down and turn
them into prison bars I'm not a lawyer
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers the lawyers are lawyers get rid
of the machine I've tried about getting
rid of the machines just pillows who did
this attack who did the Cyber attack so
you have you know the good Geeks and
they patch it up and they fix it and
they put up better protection virus
protection but here's what my attorney
said she said
just pillow they took the pillow phone
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the lid to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that is she said no you're not getting
my phone I said arrest me I've done
nothing wrong he said no we're not gonna
arrest you I said
[Music]
that's the worst thing for you because
your cervical nerves in your neck I will
send you some pillows I'm worried about
my legs I've tried about getting rid of
the machines okay melting down turn them
into prison bars
pillow all right thanks Mike Take Care
thank you bye anyway Donald Trump yeah
Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no
more Dropbox the drop boxes are just so
bad no more drop boxes Dickinson whole
logic and cephe
cephahide that was about a guy named a
rhino named Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real
Beauty had to give the American people
their voice back by building something
called truth truth essential
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
suchin tendulker to
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come
once said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infant trip and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
people but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about law and auto look Law and
Order in normal times roughly 40 percent
of fresh vegetables at about 40 percent
China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasmid into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business the teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while out parental for yourself
no
nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
Administration take this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements uh on Jewish
you heard them and you know them well
wow what a great new video a credit to
producer Pat on that one and we will be
expanding if you have any elements that
should be added to that by all means
please write in folks we are joining the
Barack Obama rally in progress Obama for
John fetterman let's go right to it
Trump at the top of the hour thank you
for being here this is the first of four
consecutive streams what a day
check and scary if if you're on a fixed
income I get it
so does Joe
the question is who's who's actually
going to do something about it
the Republicans who want a gun Social
Security and Medicare while giving more
tax cuts
to the wealthiest among us so much ask
us to Big corporations
I I don't think that's going to help you
[Music]
or well or is it Democrats like Joe
Biden who are lowering the cost of
prescription drugs
and helping to bring down gas prices and
whole oil companies accountable and make
health care more affordable that's the
choice in this election I mean who do
you really think knows knows more about
budgets and and stuff and having to pay
the bills Herschel Walker after us
Herschel Walker knows more come on
hahaha
who will fight to keep your family safe
the Republican politicians who want to
flood our streets with more guns voted
against more resources for police
departments or Democratic leaders who
worked with Joe Biden to pass the first
major gun safety legislation in nearly
30 years
that's what's at stake right now
[Applause]
who will fight for your friends
is it Republican politicians and
judicial appointees who think they
should get to decide who you love or
when you start a family
or as a democratic leaders who believe
the most intimate personal decisions
that we can make along
every individual American not mostly
male politicians in Washington
that's the choice in this election
that's what you have to decide hell of a
choice
and who is going to actually make
democracy work
Republicans they've already promised
they said it I'm not making this up they
said it
you can look it up
they've said they're not their top
priority they're going to spend the next
two years investigating their political
opponents Hunter
oh
I don't know how that's going to help
you where's Hunter
some of them said we're gonna we're
gonna impeach button
they're not quite sure why
or what for
but but that's
that's irrelevance of that doesn't
matter
family
young people launch a career start a
family get a mortgage
so that's one option the other option is
President Biden and Democratic leaders
who've worked together and sometimes
even gotten Republicans
against
their best instincts I guess to work
with them to create new jobs and lower
costs and fight climate change that's
the choice in this election
between politicians shouldn't Obama be
glitching and calling out people by race
in the crowd
[Music]
you just heard from Josh Shapiro
you know what Josh is focused on he he
was one of the first people ever to
endorse my campaign for president for
some reason
for some reason he looks the same and I
look a lot older I don't know why
that's fine but he had he had my back
he had my back
if you elect him you're a nice Governor
he will have your back every single day
growing the economy cutting taxes for
working people not folks who don't need
it fully funding our schools
supporting our teachers that's who Josh
is
now Josh's opponent
oh
lunatic
is willing to take
the most extreme positions on pretty
much everything
I mean
you name it
global warming
he says it's fake science
it doesn't matter what the thermometers
say
should gay people be allowed to get
married or adopt children
no
he doesn't think so
he does think it's okay to dress up in a
Confederate uniform for a staff photo at
the college where he used to teach true
and hey
it wasn't even Halloween Obama
it was it was like Casual Friday or
something
listen Pennsylvania
let's remember what century it is
and and listen
this would be funny
it would be an SNL skit
if it weren't so serious
you cannot let somebody that detached
from reality run your state
so let's get out and vote for somebody
you can trust
just the bureau
you need to vote for John fellow
[Applause]
this is a guy who has been fighting for
regular folks his whole life
you can tell just talk to him
he's just says he's just a dude he he's
just he's just like he is who he says he
is he does not pretend to be somebody
else
[Applause]
he he doesn't put on ears
he didn't treat people differently
depending on who he's talking to
you can tell what's in his heart what's
in his gut
as your Senator John will help build the
an economy that works for everyone
because that's his track record as a
mayor
as as somebody who worked with with kids
who didn't have advantages
he's going to improve our Criminal
Justice System he'll lower costs for
Pennsylvania families
and and he's better man hasn't held up
one fake badge though
[Music]
a John stroke didn't change who he is
it didn't change what he cares about
and it and it will not change who he
fights for when he gets to the United
States Senate he will fight for you
the only person John's opponent is
fighting for is himself and maybe Donald
Trump
what do I say about going
do not vote
vote
no booing just voting
look
it's it let's face it it's easy to joke
about droughts
I mean some of these you know remedies
he's pushed on TV
the the raspberry ketones lavender soap
and the palm oil for dementia oh
raspberry keychains
but you know what
that matters because it's somebody who
knows better
who knows better
is willing to sell snake oil
just to make money yep
and he's going to be willing to do
anything and say anything to get elected
even if it's not good for you
and Pennsylvania you deserve
someone
that's that's honest with you
you deserve
somebody who cares about you
you deserve somebody who will tell you
what they really think what they really
believe that won't be
looking to see what Donald Trump tells
them they should be doing or thinking
because it's Expedia
somebody who's going to work for you
every day and fight for you
and by the way
somebody who's actually from
Pennsylvania
you deserve somebody like John fetterman
and you deserve leaders who will stand
up for a woman's right to control her
own body and make her own health care
decision
I genuinely believe there are people of
good conscience who differ from me on
abortion and they should be free to make
those choices as their conscience guides
them
[Music]
but we should all agree that women
everywhere whatever their economic
station whatever States they live in
should be able to control what happens
with their own bodies
Josh's opponent
Josh's opponent says he thinks both
women who get an abortion and the
doctors who help them who treat them
should be prosecuted jail the fetus
John's opponent said the decision about
whether to have an abortion should be
made uh quote women doctors and local
political leaders local politicians yeah
city council member school who exactly
should tell you
when to start a family
you should make that decision
and if that's not worth 15 minutes of
your time
the amount of time it takes to vote I
don't know what is
but
if you need
another reason to go vote
consider the fact that democracy really
is on the benefit
Democrats may not be perfect
I'm the first one to admit it
I I wasn't I wasn't perfect
Joe he'll tell you wait listen you you
you're making decisions all the time
we're all human
we all got foibles
but right now at this moment
with a few notable exceptions
most Republican politicians aren't even
pretending that the rules apply to them
anymore
they're they're not even pretending that
facts apply anymore they just make stuff
up
Josh's opponent was at the Capitol on
January 6th yep he was there I mean and
and and you know he wasn't just an
observer
John's John's opponents hire people who
were there to work on his campaign he
decided Well now yeah I don't know if it
was the guy with the Viking hat or or
who but he decided that's I need that
guy on my campaign
huh
both of them ever to this day have
refused to say that Joe Biden won the
last election
now now listen I I understand that
democracy might not seem like a top
priority right now especially when
you're worrying about paying the bills
but
when true democracy goes away
we've seen throughout history
we've seen around the world
when true democracy goes away people get
hurt it has real consequences this is
not an abstraction
governments start telling you what books
you can read and which ones you can
dissidents start getting locked up
reporters start getting locked up if
they're not Towing the party line
corruption Reigns because there's no
accountability
people get hurt there are consequences
there's a reason why Generations
of Americans fought and died for our
democracy there's a reason why
suffragists and union members and civil
rights activists marched and struggled
and in some cases gave their lives
for this precious thing
this experiment in self-governance
[Applause]
they understood how precious it was
they fought
to broaden and expand who would be
included
in We the People
and they understood that when democracy
Withers
it's hard to restore
you can't take it for granted
you have to work for it
you have to nurture
you have to fight for it
now the good news is
you get
to make a difference
as long as you turn out to vote
you can fight for it as long as you turn
out to vote
you can bolster and strengthen our
democracy as long as you get out there
and do what needs to be done
you know we vote uh we joke in my
household that uh Michelle
you know she got a dazzling spot yeah
I mean
listen I understand there's in terms of
popularity there's basically Michelle
Malia Sasha
Sonny our dog
and me I understand
she's hot
she's smart
cheers
just Charming she's intelligent I I get
it but here here's a here here's a
little secret about Michelle you know
in our household she can be a little bit
of a the glass half empty person
sometimes
you know she she she can she can get a
little discouraged about what she sees
happening
and you know I'm I'm the hope and change
God
so I'm usually a little more optimistic
and so if she's been watching the news
or or reading the papers and some crazy
stuff is taking place which is basically
every 10 minutes
you know she can get them all down and
and I'll say hey honey everything's
gonna be okay
and I believe that
I believe things will be okay
but I also know that things won't be
okay on their own
they'll be okay
if we
make the effort
it'll be okay if we work for it not just
on Election Day but every day in between
[Applause]
and and I know look I know some of you
probably feel like Michelle does
sometimes because I feel even me the
hope and change guy I can get
discouraged
politics is so nasty and mean and and
it it just seems like people will say
anything and do anything
and and it
and it can be depressing sometimes
I'll say
and a lot of what we used to take for
granted
things like
respect and common decency democracy
telling the truth and believing in
science and the idea that every vote
should count and that the person with
the most votes win
all that somehow has become
controversial
but
I was listening back station what Josh
talked about
the experience of him running for
governor and traveling around the state
it reminded me of the experience that I
had first as a state senator traveling
around my district and then as the U.S
Senate candidate in Illinois and then as
a presidential candidate it's a it's
such a privilege to be able to to meet
people from every Walk of Life folks who
look different and and live in different
places and
and it would always remind me
and what we have to remind ourselves
is that there's this Common Thread
there's this thing that binds us
together
As Americans
a belief that no matter who we are or
where we come from what we look like who
we love what our last name is how we
worship
a belief that all of us matter
the kind of slash and burn
politics that we're seeing right now
that doesn't have to be Who We Are
we can be better
and and and it has nothing to do by the
way with political correctness or being
too woke
it's about fundamental values that my
grandparents from Kansas taught me
values I grew up with values you grew up
with values we try to teach our kids
values we learn in churches and mosques
and synagogues and temples honesty
fairness opportunity hard work values to
Josh Shapiro and John's Edelman stand
for values that Joe Biden stands for
values that were enshrined in our
founding documents a few miles from here
a Clarion call for freedom and equality
that Billy's own Liberty Bell represents
that's what America stands for Obama
that's who we are
so if you're anxious and frustrated
right now
don't complain
don't mope
don't tune out
get off your couch and do what
put down your phones and do what
vote for Josh Shapiro vote for John
fetterman
vote for leaders who will fight for you
and your families
both for folks who will fight for that
big inclusive hopeful forward-look in
America that we believe in
who will work with Joe Biden to build a
country that is more fair and more just
and more equal and more free
that's our task let's get to work I love
you Philly
[Applause]
well there is former president Barack
Obama
shockingly not soaking wet and dripping
with sweat
not insulting specific people in the
crowd
uh not glitching notably
not demanding that protesters be knocked
around
or gotten the hell out of there
a very very very different experience
than many of us have become accustomed
to over the last few years that is uh
Pennsylvania a critical absolutely
critical state two really good
candidates fetterman's a good guy and a
smart guy with mostly the right politics
Josh Shapiro how can anyone be upset
about Josh Shapiro the guy running
against him is a lunatic
Shapiro's just a basic Center left
Democrat he will allow whoever gets the
most votes to without resistance getting
the electoral votes in Pennsylvania in
2024.
think about how low the bar has gotten
it's in the toilet okay
Josh Shapiro will as Governor not try to
steal the electoral votes from the
person who gets the most votes from
voters
think about that think about that
so this is these are your options here
on the Democratic side of the ticket in
Pennsylvania
now I hate to even have to do this guys
I hate to even have to do this
but we are standing by for Donald Trump
as well
on the other side of this Fiasco
are Mehmet Oz and Doug mastriano
Donald Trump will shortly be making the
case that you should vote for them
I believe my audience
is mostly more than intelligent enough
to make that decision now the clowns who
are going to email me and say David how
dare you speak over my president Trump
you must be a demo rat why don't you if
is and or go back to ER country Mexico
even though I'm from Argentina that's
how they would write it to me I I you
know the grammar errors and all that
okay
other than those people
I know you all are going to see you you
just heard Barack Obama
talk about Josh Shapiro and John
fetterman
and then you're going to hear Donald
Trump talk about Doug mastriano and
Mehmet Oz
if he even remembers to because mostly
the rallies are about Trump all right
let's take care of some housekeeping and
a few different things this is the
second stream in three days it's also
the first of four consecutive streams
tonight
is the Obama rally and the Trump rally
in Pennsylvania
tomorrow we will have for you again and
basically back-to-back format
Bernie Sanders rally tomorrow night and
then the Trump rally for Marco Rubio but
run death santis isn't invited okay
that's tomorrow night that's the next
stream that'll be three streams in four
days
Monday night will be the final night
before election results
uh and we will be live with Trump in uh
wait Trump's going to be I think Trump
is in Ohio
for JD Vance we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel and then I think Obama and Biden
Monday night's gonna be absolutely crazy
that'll be the fourth stream in five
days and third in a row and then Tuesday
night it will be the crescendo the
climax and subsequent denuma I don't
know what it's going to be on Tuesday
but Tuesday we will have election
results starting at um sometime between
7 and 8 P.M eastern time now a lot of
you are saying David hold on a second
that's all that all sounds great and all
sir
but if the stream just started how do
you already have
335 new members
what I started on Thursday night is we
have a goal of a thousand by election
day
and if we make it early we're gonna go
for two all right
I have to thank right now Wesley Taylor
Wesley Taylor just signed up on my
website
15 gifted memberships okay Wesley
doesn't have a lot of money wealthy's
not Wesley's not a wealthy guy now I
actually I don't know that Wesley may be
very wealthy but it just makes the story
better okay so let's just go with
Wesley's not a wealthy guy
but Wesley understands what the right
wing does that the left often doesn't
they fund the think tanks
they fund the college groups
they fund Independent Media
Wesley gets it Wesley just gave his last
hundred dollars to the show Wesley no I
know it's not true Just go with it okay
Wesley is on the street right now for
Independent Media
okay
so help us get to this to this goal this
is a worthy goal uh it's the biggest
goal we've ever had let's add in
everybody who subscribed via twitch and
that includes the following people
uh Captain smile physicist Harry
mushroom wand
uh a tile drizzle
life is good AMJ okay that's seven plus
three fifty Seven plus zero zero three
five zero okay that puts us to 357. look
at what's happening in Latrobe
Pennsylvania here at the Trump rally if
this doesn't look good to you
I know and people are saying it doesn't
look good oh and sorry C missile as well
putting us at 358.
we absolutely must vote let's briefly
mention the polls people have been
writing in saying David but the polls
the polls might be overstating
Republican support or they might be
understating this or the polls might be
uh you know they might be Trump's toilet
paper who the hell knows what it is okay
do not worry about the polls the polls
are something we talk about because we
talk about how where is the momentum is
there momentum for Republicans yes we're
48 with 72 hours from the election
forget about the polls you get one vote
use it
okay
if Sarah Palin is down 8 or 10 in Alaska
you get one vote you get to use it on
Tuesday whatever state you live in you
just you got to use that vote
okay
that's where we are right now
that is quite simply where we are right
now
um
David will you bring back hatred mail if
there's a Blue Wave on Monday
uh well it would be Tuesday Hey listen
alien let's first get through Tuesday
then we'll talk about hatred mail okay
let's not let's not get ahead of
ourselves thanks to crowbars forever and
the notorious Rob for twitch Prime
subscriptions thank you to Lloyd who
just dumped in 20 subscriptions via
twitch 20 subscriptions via twitch folks
this is it okay the expectation is
Monday November 14th Donald Trump is
going to announce he is running for a
second term
the hell and the [ __ ] show that is going
to be Unleashed at that point in time if
we are not ready is going to be
absolutely insane okay we are there
this election on Tuesday will determine
do the election Stealers get put in
charge
for 2024.
and that's a very scary proposition
that's a very very scary proposition
look at the insanity of these people in
Pennsylvania
okay
we absolutely have to be prepared for
what is coming here
um
I don't even know where else to go with
any of these things oh
right uh
what okay so listen
we've got to build the ecosystem most of
this stuff is free okay
we all have podcasts all your favorite
left-wing shows have podcasts they're on
all the platforms Okay iTunes
subscribe to all the podcasts okay you
don't even have to listen to the
episodes or maybe you watch on YouTube
or whatever subscribe to all the
podcasts the right does this stuff they
know listen I don't care if I'm not
listening to Charlie Kirk
talk about how great Marjorie Taylor
Green is
I'm subscribed to Charlie Kirk's podcast
I'm subscribed to his YouTube channel
I'm probably a member here there the
other thing okay it's free subscribe to
everybody's podcast
um if you're watching on YouTube
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel we just got our October
numbers in October okay we had
three wait hold on uh three 3.2 million
people
who watched clips
and are not subscribed to our Channel
okay so we say oh you know in the
left-wing media space it's it's not like
the right You've Got The Young Turks
with several million subscribers and
then you've got David Pacman and and
Brian Tyler Cohen right around 1.5
million and then then it's then it's
below
well we could get there with the
audience we have right now 3.2 million
people in October watched Clips didn't
subscribe on YouTube it is free whoever
you watch doesn't have to be me make
sure you're subscribed we have 3.2
million people floating around out there
that's like the crowd tonight at Trump's
rally if you can imagine that not
subscribed all right this stuff is free
so so it you we can do it okay we can
build this thing way way way bigger than
it currently is and then yes I mean
listen
at the end of the day
all these shows
depend on the audiences so I would love
it love it love it if you grabbed a
membership on my website okay we have a
goal of getting to a thousand by Tuesday
we're at 380. we're making great Headway
sign up at joinpakman.com if you have a
membership you can gift them to others
if you want a free membership go to
davidpackman.com free membership and
sign up there okay
davidpackman.com free membership this is
super simple coupon code above my head
is indict you just type in the code
indict okay if it's a gift here's the
box is this a gift if it is you check it
if it's not you don't check it you type
in indict you get a discount okay really
really easy you want an even bigger
discount take it coupon code Obama okay
drops it even more this stuff is really
really simple you can do monthly right
it's a dollar ninety two that's all
we're talking about here we're not
talking about anything crazy
nothing nothing crazy here
um let's do it folks and I will thank
everybody I want to say thank you to
Desiree Delong Wesley Taylor Wesley
Taylor Julie Morgan Kyoko is here Kyoko
from Tokyo by the way
last time Kyoko called in from Tokyo I
described my miso soup recipe to Kyoko
she believes I may be better at making
miso soup than she is she lives in Tokyo
okay think about that when you sign up
think about that when you go to bed
tonight all right thanks to Wesley and
Kyoko for dumping in a couple more
memberships Wesley continues dumping in
memberships uh that is another eight
putting us at 388. folks whatever
happens on Tuesday remember
you can always move to Connecticut Rhode
Island or Massachusetts no sorry sorry
that's not what I meant no that that's
not the right strategy but you might
want to who knows okay we can talk about
that later whatever happens on Tuesday I
believe it is only the beginning Trump
has his new plane or his old plane
repainted as you can see here
he has landed Trump is almost certainly
announcing his candidacy November 14th
this there this is going to be a fight
this is going to be a fight for
democracy this is going to be a fight on
the airwaves this will be a fight on the
internet it will be a fight for
Reproductive Rights it will be a fight
for all of these different things
uh
uh we are only at the start we're only
at the start look at what is happening
on Twitch thank you to nullinvode null
and void micro Kimmy an anonymous gifter
Demars tiger girl and sunshine Dragon
putting us at 394.
on the website I want to say thank you
to Kyoko and Julie Morgan gifting
subscriptions thanks to Wesley Taylor
and Kyoko with another gift and Juan
folks we we can't let like three people
be doing all the subscribing I I don't
think that that's appropriate for them
how about this we're at 399 number 400
you get a free item from my online store
free I'll send it to you anywhere in the
world
go to joinpakman.com use a code don't
whatever number 400 you get a free item
from my online store super chats thank
you for all of your work David Holly
thank you
thank you for being here Holly I really
appreciate that if you're just joining
us free pillows for everyone no no
pillows
um if you're just joining us we already
covered the Barack Obama rally for John
fetterman and Josh Shapiro Obama we now
are standing by for Donald Trump he was
scheduled to speak 12 minutes ago his
plane has apparently just landed it
looks like the rally is at the airport
which is convenient I guess a thank you
to William
McClellan yes McLellan who just gifted
five subscriptions on YouTube I'm gonna
count those but we're still opening it
up to the the next person on the website
gets the free item because that's what I
said it would be
trig these and coupon
as well as tiger girl and another
anonymous gifter jumping in Via twitch
which I appreciate all right free item
folks free item from the online store
goes to Julie Morgan Julie please email
info davidpackman.com to grab it
thanks to Julie Morgan Wesley Taylor
Kyoko and Marjorie Milner are continuing
to gift subscriptions thanks to Kevin
John Robert Baker as well Kyoko dumping
in another one in Wesley
uh Rachel sheeters Desiree de long as
well as Julie Morgan wow folks that's
another 11 putting us at 419. what's the
plan for Tuesday okay I hope that you
will join me on Tuesday I'm going to be
here live we're going to be live with
the election results we will be
monitoring house we will be monitoring
Senate gubernatorial
I I just want to be up front
it could get pretty ugly on Tuesday
now I'm I'm I can tolerate it
and I'm glad for you to be here with me
but it's going to be uh it's going to be
a potentially a long night and a
difficult night but
listen the the polling genuinely may be
overstating Republican support
and uh people saying what about Bernie
okay so listen
we did Obama and Trump tonight we've got
Bernie tomorrow all right I can't cover
everything every stream so we're doing
Bernie tomorrow I hope you'll join me
again
okay
and uh
then we'll have the results on Tuesday
super chats continue to come in will you
vote for Trump in the 24 primary if data
suggests it's the best strategy for
Democrats
um I I vote in the Democratic primary
so
I guess not
David sir please give us another Trump
audio glitch by the way guys we have
this now so producer Pat made this and
and I think it's quite good if Trump
goes to the Biden glitch compilation
today we'll go to this if anyone Donald
Trump yeah Donald Trump I love Donald
Trump but no more droppa the Dropbox
isn't just so bad no more drop boxes
Dickinson hologic and cephe hide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
the American people
[Music]
truth essential I voted against Kate's
law and he voted for Obama Obama
you know we've endorsed Dr Oz we've
endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
suchin tendulker two Viro Colleen as the
great religious teacher Swami Vive
okay anyway I'm not gonna play the whole
thing now I have a feeling we might get
some pretty good use out of that during
the rally okay so uh all right where is
the white paper beautiful question okay
the white paper should be out this week
we essentially put the finishing touches
on the white paper
the name of this white paper which is
going to be free to everybody I've
determined the name it's going to be
called building arguments without
Burning Bridges this is what we're doing
it's a white paper
I get calls all the time people call me
often they're crying and they say sir
my mom believes she will become magnetic
if she gets the vaccine
or my uncle believes that John F Kennedy
Jr is currently in a gay relationship
with Hunter Biden rather than dead
and secretly running
Liberia you know or whatever right
Insanity complete Insanity and people
say to me
how do I handle that how do I handle
that
we have written and everybody's had a
hand in it the entire team plus a
researcher okay we've written we could
call it a white paper or we could call
it a guide that will tell you exactly
it's it's eight it's eight or ten pages
right so it's not every detail but it'll
give you an overview
how to approach these conversations
how to prepare for a Socratic method of
questioning
how to get people to think about why
they believe the things they believe
knowing you can't be an expert on every
one of these hair brain conspiracy
theories okay this we are giving away
for free so when people say oh David you
know where where is my membership money
going when people sign up for
memberships they go where's the money
going give me an accounting of where the
money's going well it goes to produce
the daily podcast
fund equipment connectivity salaries
health insurance
the second YouTube channel Pac-Man Live
the third YouTube channel Pac-Man
Finance
and also it goes to now hiring writers
and getting the white Papers written it
will be free we're just gonna give it
away I see it as a public service the
more people that want the white paper
we're just going to give it away okay so
we're just setting up like a landing
page on the website right now to figure
out the best way to do it uh and it's
gonna be good all right so free white
paper beautiful
I wish Obama after Trump so we could end
the night with a great speech I know
yeah I couldn't control the schedule
sadly
the white paper people are saying where
do I get it the white paper will be
released this week okay it hasn't been
released yet
it's a guide guys people are like what's
a white paper it's a guide the paper
it's gonna be uh it's gonna be legal
sized paper yeah exactly
all right David why are you not selling
or advertising on my pillow pillow
competitor Vengeance for no free pillows
just pillowed yeah I don't know I I just
don't know we have uh we have
advertisers that do bedding and stuff
like that I don't know if you mean why
am I not advertising it like literally
right now the white paper will actually
be blue that's the surprising thing
about it it's going to be legal sized
paper and blue
so to call it a white paper might be a
bit of an exaggeration a bit of a
misnomer
I think might be better said
uh okay people want a single Whitney
voicemail let me see if I can find one
um
let me see here
um Tucker Carlson oh no that's Troy York
hold on do I have anything from Whitney
I don't know that I do
let me see hey David nope that's Troy
York as well
they both try to block their numbers so
sometimes I mix up which is which
is this Whitney
hey David sorry it's almost dead nope
nope I think I have nothing from Whitney
my friends I think I have nothing guys
if you needed any better sign that Trump
is running It's the Return of the
airport rally with the Trump plane okay
that basically tells us everything we
need to know
uh okay let me say thanks to a few other
people thanks to ejm uh who just gifted
five subscriptions via twitch also want
to say thanks to null and void and tiger
girl each of whom gifted five of their
own thanks to DJ White Rabbit
Eternal troll as well putting us at 4
36. folks I think we're going to be able
to make it to a thousand uh by uh by by
next week I'm Sorry by Tuesday it is
technically next week okay I need to
thank people signing up on the website
Wesley Taylor gifting Julie Morgan
gifting welcome to Adam party Wesley
Taylor with another Wesley Taylor with
another gift welcome to Robin Duff
Wesley Taylor keeps gifting them two
more welcome to Charles Conklin Lisa
Rader with a gift Wesley Taylor with
another gift welcome to Stephanie Dean
Stephanie great to have you Stephen
Rafferty is here Wesley just sent
another gifted membership and another
James Devine is a new member thanks to
Robert Mabry Wesley Taylor and I hope
I'm pronouncing this correctly is it
kahindi Washington I really apologize if
I mispronounced that but I do appreciate
the support that is 19 putting us at 4
55. uh and that is uh Thursday and today
combined super chats keep coming in have
you noticed how Trump grips the podium
with one shoulder raised high in great
discomfort as he reads the prompter
reading is hard sometimes yeah
Trump will often grip it as he glitches
sometimes the super hard gripping is uh
sort of like a signal that he's about to
glitch
and uh
uh it happens to all of us it happens to
all of us just out of curiosity let's
listen to what the commentary is here
ladies and gentlemen
if this is the right time I don't want
to be wrong America rally to a top
candidate excuse me
so you can see that on our website and
our Rumble Channel and our app they will
all be archived the music's getting a
little lower I'm gonna see if they have
an announcement so I'm gonna pause for
one second
all right I don't think they're making
any announcements yet I'm sure they're
getting everything situated on the plane
yeah yeah but thank you all for tuning
in and don't forget we're gonna have
Vanessa Broussard we're gonna have
Matthew Alvarez live tomorrow night in
Miami Florida oh Vanessa Bruce Broussard
is going to be there that's um
that's that's pretty big yeah
um
oh and thanks Wesley just just gifted
one more membership how do you get a
free membership just go to
davidpackman.com free membership we're
just giving them away guys okay
very very simple stuff all right let's
listen to a couple of voicemails here
David sir we're watching the Stream
just curious why there's a giant empty
Blue Square in the top right hand corner
it seems like a waste of a screen real
estate beautiful question fun thanks
okay
these are really old stream overlays
there's always an endless list of stuff
that we can and should be doing
we need to update the overlays we used
to have animations that would play up
there okay when somebody would sign up
and it would be like me chugging a beer
or different things
they broke at some point when something
updated also the logo down below is old
so here's my request
if you can do some new not not this
caller if there's someone in the
audience who wants to help us with some
new live stream overlays where we can
update the logo and kind of just make
the space more usable
I would love that
I would love that okay so get in touch
info davidpackman.com we're going to get
it all fixed up it's all going to make
sense We're not gonna have any wasted
real estate I think that that's a great
idea thanks to Daniella for sending a
beautiful Super Chat I appreciate that
also thank you to Mark grazdi and
William mcgreal who just signed up at
joinpakman.com appreciate that very very
much
let's hope the paper the toilet paper
stuck to Trump's shoe does not have a
skid mark says Kilgore trout yes that
would be embarrassing
let's hope that that is not the case
today
welcome to Milo Wilde for resubscribing
on Twitch and thanks to an anonymous
gifter as well this is quite a
delegation unloading from Trump's plane
here and as you can imagine only the
best people only the best people ever
ever ever
I hope you will be with me tomorrow
there was there are competing rallies
tomorrow as well we will have a Bernie
Sanders rally and we will have another
Trump rally for Marco Rubio that'll be
tomorrow
and then um there's Ohio rallies on
Monday and then election results on
Tuesday we are doing all of it we are
doing all of it and I can't wait to have
you there for it how long do I expect
Trump to speak to speak tonight well
let's see
Latrobe PA weather
oh it's 71 degrees Trump might go two
hours yeah if it's super cold or super
hot
it can push Trump to go shorter which is
great
71 is eminently comfortable so I think
we might be in for like a Fidel Castro
you know Hugo Chavez style hours and
hours and hours tonight that which is a
scary thing
how does a progressive woman survive
living in a red State for the next few
years says Sarah shout out to Laura
thanks DP well
I don't know that I'm like the right
person to say because I'm not a woman
and I don't live in a red state
um
so
I feel for you but I don't know the
answer to that
maybe find a blue City in that red State
no no
do I really think Trump will speak more
than two hours today I think it'll be
close to two hours more than likely
thanks to Jewel Z Jewels for the twitch
Prime subscription your number 461.
Super chat's coming in Shrek says this
rally is practically in my backyard it's
two minutes from my house drove past it
earlier so surreal to see these freaks
in person I know
I Can Only Imagine
why do you think the Republican party is
terrified of prompt can I get an Obama
Obama well I don't know that they're
they're terrified of trump
if Trump wins and they're on Trump's bad
side they're terrified of losing access
which is a common thing among
politicians s Prez just dumped in 40
subscriptions via twitch putting us at
501 ladies and gentlemen we are heading
towards a thousand in support of
Independent Media and five streams in
six days
we are
50.1 percent of the way there
is that right is my math right I don't
even know
welcome to Andy Yamashiro as well
who is number 502 and welcome to Leslie
onstad who just signed up on the website
folks I I can't believe this is
happening
I just had I got three emails from
people saying David can you sign me up
for the free membership no no no
there is only one way to get in line for
a free membership
I have here okay listen Glenda just
wrote to me Glenda I love you Glenda
okay I am so appreciative of the fact
that you're watching I understand you're
62. you're on a fixed income Glenda I
we love you here
davidpackman.com free membership
davidpackman.com free membership
that's how you get a free membership it
is it's not by emailing me okay with
peace and love with peace and love peace
and love do not email me about the free
memberships I can't do anything for you
that's a Boeing
757-200 says Dave built in 1991. such
extravagance by this billionaire h-e-i-r
right
right right
uh beautiful plane beautiful plane
I don't know I really don't care too
much about Trump's plan I wouldn't be
caught dead on a 757 but no actually you
know the truth is I have to tell you in
american commercial Aviation
there are actually some there's a bunch
of flights where the 757 is your best
option
um there there's some uh a couple
Airlines like uh United and Delta have
refreshed the 757 which correct me if
I'm wrong
I believe the 757 is the largest single
aisle plane
and um
first you know like a there's some New
York to LA Boston to San Francisco some
of those flights the best product
uh is the 757. so nothing to sneeze at
nothing to sneeze at
that particular plane smells like
McDonald's yeah no I know I'm saying I I
haven't flown on Trump's 757.
he'll be out any minute okay everybody
relax thanks to Big D the joke revamped
is dead as well for the twitch Prime
subscriptions thank you very much
welcome to Jessica Hecker Jessica thank
you Jessica just signed up on my website
and is ready to go for what is going to
be a very very large week of streaming
wide week and long week of streaming I
expect uh will there be no I don't think
there will be 40 hours of streams well
hold on let me think
Thursday no no no not 40 hours but it
could be 20.
it could be 20 certainly
um
which is which is exciting let's see
what they're talking about here we've
got the YMCA on one of President Trump's
favorite dances and the crowd loves it
again over nine hours they've been
waiting all day they've waited through a
rainstorm do you guys think that if you
wait nine hours for a trump rally is it
morally more likely that you are
let me give you the three options but
people are already saying let me give
you the three options if you wait nine
hours for a trump rally okay
are you more likely
a brainwashed cultist
mentally ill
or you just have a really sad boring
life where it's quite literally the only
thing to do
all three oh my God okay yeah that's
yeah everybody's saying it's all three
well that's sad
that's sad
Henrik Madsen is here with a 500 Danish
kroner Super Chat the biggest of the day
as the orange Menace exits his plane
Hendrick says hey Pac-Man we've got to
spice it up every time you use obamna or
there is someone in chat who writes
Obama you need to drink wine beer or
whiskey so Henrik I love the Super Chat
drinking games are not allowed on any of
the streaming platforms that we are on
so we're not going to be doing that
that's a pass Henrik really appreciate
the support I don't even know how much
uh 500 Danish kroner is let's see oh
it's 66 US Dollars that's very generous
love the suggestion can't do it okay we
just can't do it uh here is Donald Trump
thanks to Brian Robertson for signing up
on my website putting us at 507 as we
make rapid progress towards our goal of
a thousand
oh God this one's gonna be bad David are
you looking forward to the new video
posting and content monetization
opportunities on Twitter I don't I
haven't heard about them Joe what's
going to happen
actually it would be useful to know if
someone can email me about video
monetization stuff that Elon Musk is
doing please email me about it I know
that he's going to charge eight bucks
for verification which doesn't sound
great but let me know I want to hear
about that
first found you when you interviewed
someone I'm a fan of you seem to think
negatively of the person but I respected
your views well thank you very much
I went from lifer Republican to a Bernie
fan over the covet shutdown because of
you thank you for the work you do well
welcome Crystal you're very much welcome
here I appreciate that
thanks to Jenna atanasoff and Karen High
both signed up on my website as Donald
Trump is getting ready to uh have a very
serious case of verbal diarrhea maddened
has just signed up via twitch Prime and
says thanks for the great content and
coverage of important events hard to
imagine something more important right
now
than these elections so I'm glad to have
you here and welcome to Tanya Thomas who
is new member what 511 today it is 71
degrees in Pennsylvania that is a too
comfortable for Trump although he does
already seem a little bit sweaty so our
only hope is that 71 for Trump is hot
and that that will cause him to speak
less time
let's listen we already heard from
Barack Obama earlier
[Applause]
man these are great people great
terrible audio huh to the governor's
mansion you're going to elect the
incredible slate of true America First
Republicans
up and down the ballot we're going up
and down the ballot like they've never
seen before and we're going to end crazy
Nancy Pelosi's political career once and
for all
yeah
you know they had a little rally here
nobody showed up for their rally look at
this rally
and then they'll say how many votes they
got tell it's wonderful right this is
the biggest poll you can have and we
always had this poll except now it's
bigger and better and stronger than
we've ever had it before Oh God under
Biden Pelosi Schumer and the radical
democrat congress your Commonwealth is
being totally destroyed our country is
being destroyed Biden and the far left
lunatics are Waging War on Pennsylvania
energy crushing Pennsylvania jobs
gutting Pennsylvania communities and
strength this audio is a disaster with
soaring prices like you've never seen
before
inflation is costing the typical
household nearly eight hundred dollars
every single month congratulations at
the rally on Thursday he said it was 700
now it's 800 two days later wow going
the southern border is wide open
millions of illegal aliens are pouring
into our country your Commonwealth is
enduring a massive and bloody crime way
and the far left is indoctrinating our
children with Twisted race and gender
Insanity in our schools
other than that they're doing a
fantastic job
there's only one choice to end this
madness and it is indeed Madness if you
support the decline and fall of America
then you must vote for the radical left
Democrats
if you want to stop the destruction of
our country and save the American dream
then this Tuesday you must vote
Republican in a giant red way
there is no more urgent task for the
future of our country than to stop The
Invasion on our Southern border nobody's
ever seen anything like it two years ago
we had the strongest Southern Border in
American history by far now it is the
worst border I believe anywhere in the
world there's no third world country
that would allow
what's happening here to happen to them
if they had to use sticks and stones to
keep people out they would do it nobody
would allow what they are doing to our
country nobody would allow it no third
world country would allow it Biden
Pelosi and the radical Democrats spend
all their time obsessing over the
borders of distant foreign Nations that
you've never even heard of in most cases
Americans deserve a Congress and a
president who will protect the borders
of our nation
[Music]
and we deserve a government that will
defend our sovereignty secure our land
stand up for our families and protect
the people of our country
[Music]
thank you
all right
okay
Mike
Mike what a cult it's called America
first or it's called Maga you know what
Maga stands for make America great again
I watched Biden two days ago in a fit of
rage anger he's so angry
we've got to stop Maca calls it mega
mega Ultra maga maga King I'm the Mega
King he said I'm the Mega King we've got
a
is a very good compliment actually the
magazine we've got to stop the magic
King
Dom we're gonna stop the Mega King get
the FBI loaded up get the justice
department loaded for six years I've
been going through this stuff
a friend of mine said you have to be the
most honest person ever and it'll take
you out in about three days you know six
years and by the way we have tonight
with us Uncle Sam stand up Bill look at
this guy he's the greatest
he follows me all over the place I don't
do anything he follows me look at him
he's Central that guy's probably very
very ill
it's the casting he's great
I think he made a lot of money someplace
but he comes here to every how many
rallies have you attended Uncle Sam
[Music]
too many it's his birthday happy
birthday
wow what a great guy
nah we have people that have been to
over 130 rallies we have some people
from North Carolina some incredible
women 93 they're up to 93 but we have
many people that are almost everyone I
think Mike almost everyone we have some
people say what do they do for a living
they're following the rally well here we
are here we are it's a Saturday night in
Pennsylvania is there anything better
than going to a trump rally on a
Saturday night in Pennsylvania
getting blood drawn probably
unfortunately we have so many bad things
happening to our country we can't
celebrate until we start winning we have
to win and we're going to win a lot
we're going to win in 22 which is a few
days we're going to win in 24 we're
taking back that beautiful house
in 2021 an average of 15 Pennsylvania
lives were lost to drug overdoses every
single day think of that 15 every single
day yet Biden and the radical Democrats
do nothing to stop the lethal poisons
pouring across our border most of it
comes right second border right over our
Southern border it comes right right
into our country they don't even bother
with the airports they don't bother with
them it just pours in and we had it
stopped we had the safest Border in
history and now we have the worst think
of that since the end of the Trump
Administration the drug cartels have
seen their revenue Skyrocket by an
astounding 2 500 percent
think if that was a public company the
stock would be uh at quite a price
wouldn't it uh two thousand five hundred
percent in two years the choice this
election is simple Democrats will defund
the police Republicans will to fund the
cartel are there any national Democrats
running on defund the police is is there
even a single one that you can point to
four on the cartels and we were very
very successful we ended Catch and
Release I don't know Asylum fraud we
rounded up aliens we took alien gang
members all illegally in our country by
the thousands and thousands MS-13
everyone we got him the hell out of our
country
we took care of it and you know their
countries didn't want to take them back
you know the El Salvador Honduras they
didn't want to take them back Mexico but
I said to
our people Mexico what do we give like
Honduras El Salvador how much do we pay
these countries sir the total for the
three countries
750 million dollars a year that's a lot
I said well they're not taking them back
they wouldn't take them back under the
Biden Administration you know they went
to send MS-13 back to these various
countries they wouldn't take them back
so our people gave up they said they
won't take them I said differently I
said how much do we pay 750 million so
are the audio problems two-fold one that
there's like too much uh that the level
is too hot and then also that like the
speakers in the back are feeding back
are those the two issues right now
following day I got a call from
Guatemala president
El Salvador Honduras the three
Mr President sir we understand you're
upset he's better you won't take uh
people back that you sent to us you're
not sending you're not taking them back
you have to take them back and they said
uh well we would be like we would love
to do that is there a problem
I said yeah you got to take you know
what they were doing they were putting
airplanes in the runway so when the
planes would come in they couldn't land
right they had to go back to wherever
they came from they were blocking up the
buses they were even blocking up the
waters you couldn't get them back so I
said
here's what you do surrounding not
getting any money what did you open up
your land and you're taking these
criminals back into your country because
most of them many of them were criminals
and they said sir we would be honored to
do so
why didn't you ask well they've been
asking for about 15 years
but we asked a little bit differently so
what an electric speech huh we had a
mass migration out of our country of
MS-13 gang members and killers and
everything else that they took him back
they took him back very quickly
sort of like another little business
store you know the Boeing the been
reading about it Boeing is complaining
now that Air Force One we have a new Air
Force One under construction because of
me no president really wanted to do it
but when I got there they said sir we'd
like you to sign this document what's a
document the document was a contract
with Boeing to buy a new Air Force One
which by the way you should do the plane
is 32 years old I think it's time you
know they come in from certain countries
especially in the Middle East their
plane's about three days old the latest
and the greatest and ours is 32 years
away the United States of America isn't
Trump's plane even older than that came
up to me from the Air Force said sure we
have the document ready I said what
document we're buying a new Air Force
One now Air Force One is actually two
planes it's two 747 800s or nine
hundreds and they're quite quite the
plane I will tell you in fact I can't
even tell you what's on this plane
because it might be top secret and
they'll try and say oh he violated
document
it's violated every Trump violated a
document geez everybody's accusing this
guy of sexual assault they got them all
over the place they have them in Chinese
restaurants and bowling alleys you know
that right
the windows are broken the doors are
broken they have no security but it's
okay for them but not for truck
now it's a disgrace what's happening to
our country but they said sir it's
something we have to do we have to buy
the plane how much is it 5.7 billion
dollars so I said that sounds like a lot
for two planes I don't care how good
they are and they do have all sorts of
things on there that we will not discuss
but 5.7 so the head of Boeing came to
see me nice guy and I said this was
before their tragedy that was a tragedy
that really destroyed it was one of the
great companies of our country and of
the world but the two planes that went
down was absolutely it was devastating
but this was before that this was when
they were thought to be the greatest
company there is is Trump going to
criticize Boeing despite the fact that
he had that he has a a Boeing plane
which he's standing in front of right
now uh he said how do you know I said
because it was negotiated by Obama
Obama and
and I said therefore I think it's too
high 5.7 billion dollars
so he said well maybe we could take
something off I said no it's got to have
a three in front of it gotta have a
three
they say what do you mean by that it's
got to have a three so he said uh well
we can't do that and he said we'll take
200 million dollars off I said no good
it's not even close nope gotta have a
three I'm sorry you got to get down to
so this is a crazy story something that
had a Boeing called me up and he said
sir
make it 5.5
billion dollars sounds like a lot for so
I said no no gotta have a three I'm
sorry no then we didn't hear from them
again and he came down to 4.9 billion I
said you're getting close another
billion you're going to be there right
and I didn't hear from him for a month
and then you know with deals time goes
by then you forget about the thing and
even if you have a great memory like I
have a great memory some of you people
have great memories
but you sort of forget because you don't
care I said gotta have a three you gotta
have a three so two months later I get a
call
head of Boeing they said what the hell
does he want I didn't think he was
talking about the plane the funny thing
is the idea of trying to build a plane
as cheaply as possible like do you want
to go with the cheapest possible build
on an airplane
and 99 cents
okay
I said you have a deal
and
so we saved 1.7 billion and that was
done and I watched the contract it was
carefully drawn and they were committed
to that deal now what happens is if
you're reading the paper over the last
couple of weeks Boeing is complaining
that the deal is terrible for them that
they're going to lose 800 million
dollars on the deal and I say well they
have to lose that but I understand the
Biden Administration is under
negotiation to bring it up so they walk
away with our big fat profit but they
shouldn't do that that was a deal they
made and every time I wait so now the
government should be able to strong-arm
private companies into losing money that
doesn't sound very pro-business like
what is he talking about and nowhere to
a company nope you got to lower your
price you don't even have to do a lot of
research and development they say why I
say the price is too high they don't say
why have you studied no and they save
hundreds we save so much money with that
but with the plane so now the planes are
a big topic of conversation and I'm very
proud to say that nobody in this
audience has ever heard of a thing like
this with respect to the United States
because we always pay so much that
everybody gets Rich all of these
companies get rich but Trump likes that
he says he's good for business I'm
watching for you so pretty I don't get
it pretty cool I'm confused Mike knows
you're great congressman
we build hundreds of miles aboard a wall
and despite two and a half years of
democrat lawsuits to stop it we want all
of them why won't Obama ever tell a
story about plane negotiations well plan
then we added much more wall in areas
where we felt we needed it and almost
got that finished too and then three
weeks all they needed was three weeks to
complete everything much more than we
ever anticipated building
and they didn't want to do it and I said
something strange here because I never
believed they wanted open borders I
never thought they were stupid because
look at the way they cheated on
elections nobody could be stupid to
cheat that well right they'd cheat so
much they cheat nobody's ever cheated
like these people cheat so they're not
stupid
so the only other answer is they hate
our country there's only one must be
they're either stupid or they hate our
country but they wanted open borders to
ravage our country and every day the
Democrat open border policies are
getting innocent American skilled no
they didn't want to finish that well
they wanted to leave parts of it open so
that we could have open borders and who
would want open borders earlier this
year in Philadelphia Savage illegal
alien criminal suspected of two prior
stabbing shot at innocent 76 year old
man in the back of the head
while the man was out Simply walking his
dog and walking around for a little
exercise last year an illegal alien in
Montgomery County I know it well
viciously murdered a 23 year old woman
with a knife stabbing her repeatedly
again and again
in her back
and then throwing her body under a pile
of trees
these are people coming into our country
and they're coming in by the hundreds of
thousands and don't believe when you
hear three million people it's 10
million people it's far more than
they're saying
and in Chester County an illegal alien
is charged with grabbing a 33-year-old
beautiful young woman by the hair
pulling her to the ground and stabbing
her to death in front of her
seven-year-old daughter and
three-year-old son
these are animals
I remember when I used that term to
describe some vicious killers and Nancy
Pelosi said these are not animals these
are human beings no they're animals
and we better get tough or we're not
going to have a country left anymore
we're not going to have a country left
when Republicans retake Congress
we must immediately Force the
restoration of every single
border security policy we had the board
had done all they had to do is come in
and do nothing everything was great
we had the great Tom Holmen has anyone
looked at him Central Casting
I'll tell you people on the border
patrol including your great leader who I
happen to
be in love with I'm not sure if he's
supposed to be as is the border wall
done or not it seems to depend whether
it's convenient for the anecdote he's
mentioning by the FBI if somebody's
doing a good job on the border they get
visited by the FBI if somebody's looking
at voter Integrity because they want
honest elections they get visited by the
FBI with all sorts of subpoenas by the
way
a woman who's incredible Engelbrecht do
you know her Catherine and Goldberg
[Music]
and another gentleman who
is fantastic and working these are
patriots they spent a year going over
hundreds of thousands of
hours of tape all over the country and
they found that ballot boxes have been
stuffed you heard about a 2 000 mules
Catherine Engelbert oh god well they
came and they arrested her none of this
is true even if she's now in a Houston
she's in a Houston prison
along with another great Patriot and you
know what they did they went out and
they saw illegal
ballot stuffing they don't know what
they're looking out of cars looking up
who walks out when you walk out to vote
you don't walk out like let's see
where's the camera what's going on
they did they did some of them voted as
much as 28 times a day and 28 different
locations yeah it's a disgrace we got to
get her out she's going to come out
she's got to get out this was not in her
agenda as she was growing up going to
good schools having parents that loved
her she said this was never in
my agenda never a word in the vocabulary
prison was not a word in her vocabulary
she's an incredible person and so are
the people that true the vote that
worked with her can you imagine they put
her in prison she's in jail
what a disgrace our country is going to
hell in so many different ways and
that's yet murder is all over the street
you have drug dealers and you have
everything rapists you have everything
and they take an unbelievable American
Patriot along with others including
January 6 people oh God including folks
the Patriots from the riots aren't being
treated fairly untreated in this country
and yet BLM and antifa burn down cities
kill people and nothing happens to them
oh he's unhinged he's extra on him
it's a disgrace it's a disgrace
two levels of Justice it says it's not
Justice it's the opposite of justice and
I said the other day to Mike
and I'm talking about our great
Congressman this Mike where do you stand
up Mike you know Mike did me on 60
Minutes the Kelly man
but he's never seen anything like it
we've never seen anything like what's
going on and the people aren't going to
take it anymore they're not going to
take it anymore
okay we're going to make America great
again we first have to make America safe
again
under the radical left crazy Democrats
the streets of our cities are ruled by
bloodthirsty gangs and violent criminals
you know that you see what's going on
I've never seen anything like it you
turn what's going to be a faster
torpedoing Elon Musk of Twitter or what
Trump did in his four years as president
much of the crime wave is caused by drug
dealers who during the course of their
lives will kill an average of 500
American citizens no evidence of that
and I'm calling right now for the death
penalty for drug dealers and human
traffickers which will upon us passes
reduce drug distribution and crime by
more than 75 percent on day one it's all
made up
thank you though
when I was in the White House you know
we'd form and we did a good job we got
it down 18 that's good but it's nothing
what about the rest would set up Blue
Ribbon committees to work on the cartels
and some of the most vicious people and
by the way smart
Street Smart like you have never seen
before they're making billions and
billions of dollars people say that our
corporations aren't run as well as some
of these cartels in terms of business no
it's a it's a terrible thing but we'd
set up a blue ribbon committee headed up
by some nice people from different
cities socialites and very fine people
and they don't have a clue but they love
being on the committee because they want
some publicity for themselves right
right and some of them want to do a job
but as soon as they look at one of these
monsters they would freeze they wouldn't
know what to do now we have to bring our
law enforcement back in and our military
if necessary back in from where
when I went to China because I actually
until
the China virus came in I had a great
relationship with China China president
XI is now president for life I call him
King he says no no no I am not King I am
president I said here's the quick trial
Story You're the king as far as I'm
concerned but I had a great relationship
with him and I said to him and you've
heard me tell the story a couple of
times that much but had a great
relationship with President XI we made
an unbelievable trade deal for our
Farmers our manufacturers 50 billion
dollars a year they have to purchase
people don't like to write the fake oh
look at all of them they must think I'm
going to announce the president tonight
that's that's a lot
a lot of people
that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people
that's a lot of oh look at all those
cameras eyes look at those cameras look
stand up look at those cameras
we want us to get some of the juice
because he has to win you know if he
I'll tell you what this could be the
vote that's going to make the difference
between a country and not a country
because we know it could be 51. it could
be 50 could be 49 and if it's 49 for the
Republicans this country I don't know if
it's going to live for another two years
that's what's happening so you got to
get he pointed to Oz but Oz was in one
of those feted porta-potties that they
put at these events thinking about that
just a little while ago somebody was on
television on the way in I'm watching
I'm very spoiled to have a nice plane
with a couple of little televisions I'm
watching
and somebody said that you know the vote
in Pennsylvania for Senate could be the
difference between having the majority
or not and he's a very good man and
we're going to talk about him in a
second but you really have to get out
you have to get out you have to vote or
we're going to have a problem because
our country has never been so bad as it
is right now it's never been in this
position we're not respected any place
we have a country as I say remember
we're significantly more respected per
Gallup International polling now than
when Trump was president
of each other we're having such a good
time and yet the subject is so negative
there's nothing good to say about what's
happening in our country but on Tuesday
night I think is going to be incredible
things to say I really believe it wow
right Kelly right wow wow yeah I think
we're gonna have incredible but you got
to get them in
if you want safety for your family and
security for your community you need to
vote every single Democrat out of office
and vote for Republicans up and down the
line
one of the worst and most Sinister
aspects of the Biden Administration is
their complete and total corruption
of our justice system and of the rule of
law nobody ever thought this happened
I had a guy named Bill Barr who was
afraid to talk to anybody because they
were going to impeach him he was afraid
no he wasn't I don't blame him they
wanted to impeach him they said we're
going to impeach him sir they go to a
peach tree I said so what I got
impeached twice my poll numbers were off
so he didn't want to look at election
fraud you know all of a sudden they said
who the hell would impeach this guy he's
the greatest thing we have
but we need tough people we need smart
people we need people that are willing
to fight before our very eyes Biden and
is left with think about all of the ways
in which the justice system is corrupted
and meanwhile Trump's like it's corrupt
because they went after me what's
happening we really skipped over I used
to say socialists we skipped over social
that took about two weeks
we're long gone from socialism we're
into communism this is getting to be
what they're doing with a Catherine
Engelbrecht and everybody
this is like a communist country all
right we can switch to the news max
speed if people if people want much of
the crime wave is caused by drug dealers
who during the course of their lives
on an average of 500 Americans this is
like delayed by 20 minutes we can't do
that guys that doesn't make any sense
Democrats are locking up pro-lice and
you know this you see pro-life pro-life
activists they're being locked up all
over the place
they're persecuting their political
opponents I wonder who
nobody a friend of mine said A friend of
mine said there's never been a president
that's been treated like you after he
gets you know when you get out of office
you go and these guys come at you left
and right on such [ __ ] you've never
seen anything like that
whoa they're spying on their political
Rivals remember they spied on my
campaign can you imagine if we would
have spied on Obama's campaign Obama
president they didn't spy on Obama
remember that what he's saying is not
true
Obama Obama's campaign or a Biden's
campaign I don't know they might not
who the hell knows I don't know Obama
the craziest thing they spied in my
campaign that would have been death
penalty God they would have brought back
the electric chair at least for a couple
of evenings got rid of a couple of them
and with us oh it's okay it's fine now
we're not going to let this happen
anymore Obama's descent and using the
full force of government law enforcement
in the media because the media those
people right there they're corrupt
largely corrupt
they are truly the enemy of the people
they are
they used to be they used to be the
police they used to be the Watchmen they
used to be the police though they would
go and look at corruption there's
corruption on the Democrats side they
don't do anything
if there's no corruption on the
Republican side they try making it up
crystal clear no they are they have so
lost their way it's not all of them they
have some incredible reporters like you
know as an example of the Pulitzer Prize
they got a good surprise New York Times
gets a Pulitzer Prize Washington Post
gets opponent surprise for outstanding
reporting on the Russia Russia Russia
hoax okay
but it turned out they were exactly
wrong it's now been as they used the
term debunked and yet they have a
Pulitzer Prize so I called for and will
be suing at some time right now I'm into
so many suits but I'm going to drop
another one very soon
but think of it
well I'm doing what good bar shot of you
Bill Barr should have been bringing
these shirts but he didn't have the guts
to bring him so I have no choice but
think of it they make up a story it's
all made up by them and then they get
Pulitzer prizes
and they were wrong and it's been and
even the times and even the Washington
Post now admit that it was wrong it was
fake it was a phony deal they've
admitted it so they should turn back
their Pulitzer prizes right so let's see
what the courts have to say we need
judges
and justices but we need judges and
justices with strength right with
courage strength
because you just had a decision recently
that basically said we were all right
two weeks ago a week ago you're all just
about all Democrat Supreme Court of
Pennsylvania said they were right the
2020 election with respect to the
ballots and everything else the 2020
election was
not right it was not right it was not
allowed and you know what I was remember
at like 9 30 in the evening with 73
percent of the vote in I was up by
almost a million votes and then all of a
sudden like magic it disappeared and I'm
so worried about and what was the status
of California at that time sir I know
we can't let this happen but so they
make a ruling
and essentially they don't want to say
this but they said Trump was 100 right
the election was rigged and stolen and
we're not going to let it happen again
so from now on right
foreign
they missed the point Mike Kelly they
missed the point now we're not going to
let it happen again so from now on you
can't do all the things they did to us
because they were illegal so then I said
well what about 20 20. no no we'll start
from now
so they cheated like dogs
and you're all Democrat mostly I think
just about all Democrat Supreme Court
said you can't do it anymore I said what
about 2020 overturned the election
and it's not just here it's other states
we're just as bad and in some cases
whereas the election was rigged and
stolen it's a shame it's a shame but the
Court ruled and I kept saying oh this is
great we won we won you know I'm going
we won we won and then it said but we'll
leave 2020 stand oh that's nice
that's nice
every freedom loving America needs to
understand the time just
irony is right now
if you want to save your rights and
Liberties you have to start by dealing a
really humiliating rebuke to the radical
left in this upcoming election on
Tuesday you got to get out and and I
like to say get out on Tuesday because
it's harder for them to cheat if you go
and vote in person right if you send in
those ballots that I can assure you
nobody on the left cares whether these
clowns vote early or on Tuesday or
whenever send it anyway this Tuesday you
have to crush the Communists at The
Ballot Box you have to there are none
remember this statement the vote counter
is always more important than the
candidate and that's what happened we
beat this guy so badly but the vote
counters they're crooked as hell these
people are crooked as hell and that's
what we have I hope people understand
that this is as crazy as as Trump's
saying I I I've never had water I only
drink antifreeze right I mean he didn't
win
he very clearly didn't win it wasn't
close there was no fraud it's crazy that
he can say something so wrong and the
crowd cheers the witch hunts hoaxes and
abuses have been coming Fast and Furious
first we learned they spy to my campaign
then they invite to Congress and lied to
the fisa court like nobody's ever lied
before
and created a fake dossier turned out to
be a fake dossier how about me going
home to our great first lady when I
first heard about this and she said
certainly I promise it didn't take place
and then they admitted it now it didn't
take place it was fake and it was made
up by crooked Hillary Clinton a Democrat
National Committee in the Democrat Party
[Music]
no but think about it think about it
folks remember they claim that they are
for Law and Order if you care about Law
and Order and they're chanting to lock
up someone who hasn't even been charged
with a crime that's not Law and Order
and it's certainly not due process this
same people keep coming back and Shifty
Adam Chef and the whole group they're
really sleaze
Adam Schiff made up my phone call he
said Trump said all of this horrible
stuff and he imitated me he went into
Congress and he made like I was speaking
and he said he said eight times a quid
pro quo and he did that and this and
that to the president of Ukraine
zielinski I like zielinski for one
particular reason
because he said that's false would have
been very easy for him to say oh I felt
so intimidated but it wasn't he was very
honorable about that I must tell you but
shift Shifty shift went before Congress
and spewed out of speech unfortunately
after he made that speech I said we have
recorded the phone call
and it was a totally phony speech I said
oh this is great now we have shift and
you know what happened they said you
can't get anybody if they're speaking
even if it's totalized in Congress
they're immune from liability I said
wait a minute he made up a statement
he's a sleaze bear he's just a
sleazeball they said I'm sorry sir he
made it in the halls of Congress and you
can lie in the halls of Congress and
there's no retribution can you believe
it
I all I can say is thank goodness we had
that conversation transcribed because it
was a perfect phone call remember it was
Russia Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine and then the Mueller Witch Hunt
where the conclusion was no collusion
and I always say do you think Biden
could say that the conclusion was no
collusion you think Biden's good so guys
we have Luke Beasley on the ground in
Latrobe Pennsylvania he just sent me a
video clip he says is a preview of his
interviews with trumpists tonight do you
want to take a minute away from the
rally to look at what what Luke said he
says there's a lot more coming or we can
just stick with this it'll just be a
minute
disinformation even though they knew
people want to do it was a legitimate
Horror Show
for Hunter Biden and for his family I
don't know what the hell happened with
this how you left it he left it with a
gentleman who's been I have not watched
this yet this is a preview from our our
correspondent On The Ground Luke Beasley
at the rally let's just see what he's
got for us and then we'll we'll get back
to the rally okay let's see what we got
here just one minute we lose the war
were any of us were born or our parents
or ancestors were born or was it the
Native Americans in the beginning or
were the white people the original
occupants of America and then they got
pushed out by it no I'm not saying I
love hip-hop culture hip-hop is like
embredded into me it's embredded oh
that's genius oh it's embredded that's a
portmanteau of embedded and bred into me
right it's embredded oh my God this is
this could be the best video ever I love
hip-hop culture hip-hop is like
embredded into me so I'm like you're
gonna be a black soul it's baked like a
loaf of bread right into him a white
body not sure
but I still have my soul and like the
soul of America is like slowly
dissipating and where did it go
by the way are all these people leaving
because I can hear Trump speaking in the
background are they are they just
walking out I thought the best was
yesterday
I fall asleep and I'm there sometimes
most of the time I drink or smoke some
weed
you jump out of an airplane in the
metaverse Can You Feel The Wind
what
how do we get there
all right guys so there it is uh well
that just don't miss the Monday show
okay it's gonna be quite a quite a scene
but only spends your time going after
Trump I'm gonna get Trump did you ever
see I'm gonna get Trump in the meantime
people are being murdered all over the
place they're being shoved into Subways
this week at her request a radical left
lunatic judge this is a judge that hates
Trump more that he's ever hated anybody
or anything in his life he's a lunatic
started a process of confiscation akin
to Venezuela Cuba or Soviet Union but
don't worry we'll be okay we've been
fighting these guys for six years we'll
be okay Uncle Sam
I don't want your help likewise a local
left-wing D.A in Atlanta is after me for
an absolutely perfect phone call I would
say even more perfect Uncle Sam than
Dakota made to the president of Ukraine
I believe it was a more perfect call it
was about election Integrity even while
Atlanta has among the highest murder
rates of any city in the country worse
than Chicago per capita
all of these local Democrat runs it's
funny how all through covid it was like
Trump didn't understand per capita and
maybe he didn't and now all of a sudden
he does even though maybe he doesn't but
he picks up on the fact that it probably
is good to mention it we're going to
straighten out this mess of a country
we're gonna straighten it out we're
gonna straighten it out
man that is a look at the people
hey Oz
if you have these people vote if you
have these people vote you can't lose
where's Doug where is Doug Doug look at
they go back you can't even see
wow
there you go
you know what I asked these guys all the
time go back you know what I ask all the
time all the time I say please tell them
look at those those cameras I say turn
them around all the way I can see turn
them to see the people now that today
they announced so they had 5 000 people
for Obama and Biden they didn't have it
looked like a crowd of 200 people that
crowd looked big actually but we have
tens of thousands of people here if
these I was actually thinking that it's
a night it was a big crowd with Obama
you can't lose
you got to get out and vote but we have
a weaponized Department of Justice and
weaponized FBI including of course
Mar-A-Lago my beautiful house
parade on Mar-A-Lago
that's in the document hoax case
violating my fourth amendment rights
like nobody's ever been violated before
they even went through the first ladies
closet
and look into a document in her
let me be nice in her dress
maybe this attack
or documented one of her shoes her
beautiful high heel
now what they did is so terrible it's
amazing and something that really it's
never happened to a president before the
radical left things by doing all of
these Wicked and venomous things that
they're making us weaker but actually
they're making us stronger and more
united in fact right now remember I
always used to talk about my poll
numbers remember I'd come out in 2016
and in 2020 because in 2020 they were
actually better but I used to come out
and it used to drive the fake news crazy
but today I have the highest poll
numbers I've ever had perhaps partly
because the Democrats are doing so badly
running our country and people want our
tremendous success of no inflation
energy Independence military Victory
remember I defeated Isis 100 remember
al-baghdadi and so many other things
including crime we had it weighed down
but we have the best poll numbers where
are they are they putting them up in the
screen I think so put them up look
[Music]
now we're putting them up we're winning
we're winning big big big in the
Republican party for the nomination like
nobody's ever seen before
let's say there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonious said
10 percent
Mike Pence at seven oh Mike's doing
better than I thought
Liz Cheney there's no way she's at four
percent
there's no way
there's no way but we're 71 to 10 to 7
to 4. Ted Cruz is doing a good job by
the way he didn't like me for a while
but we got to be friends right
could have put him on the Supreme Court
if I put him on the Supreme Court you
know the nicest thing with that because
he's a you know tough cookie and he's
controversial if I put him on the
Supreme Court I would have had 100
percent of the people in the Senate
voting in favor to move him out okay
even the Democrats would have voted for
him okay but he's great and he's smart
and he's good
uh Nikki Haley Kim Scott is great by the
way okay look at the next one what's the
next one go ahead
Trump version this is Nevada Trump us up
12. that's very good and I think that
Lombardo is doing very well he's up five
and black salt is a great guy he's up
five go ahead put the next one up let's
do this this is sort of fun these just
come out over the last joke what Ohio
I'm going to be in Ohio
for JD Vance right going to be in Ohio
for JD
so you have the Ohio general election
Trump at 55 Biden at 35 Plus 20. but we
won Ohio on a landslide they actually
counted the votes accurately we won Ohio
but now we're up at 20 which is much
higher than it was even for the election
go ahead what's the next one this stuff
is great what's the next one
okay North Carolina oh we love it
Donald Trump 51 Joe Biden 40.
Plus 11.
Oz I want to get you these numbers these
are good numbers for you you should be
leading by more than anybody you're so
good go ahead what's next we're leading
big in North Carolina Lara by the way
from North Carolina she loves Eric's
wife Laura she's so terrific she's done
a great job she's been great then we
have and by the way Ted bud what a great
candidate he's been to
Trump 47 Biden 41 what's that that's a
general election presentation
oh I see Psalm 47 41 in the genetic
sure I'm happy with that number how the
hell I don't know if I like that then
but how the hell did that one get up
there
I'm only leading by six in the general
election I think that's a mistake but
Rasmussen is very good so who knows go
ahead put it up please is that it okay
here we go general election
oh that's better Donald Trump 50 Biden
37 plus 13. that's what I like to hear
that stuff how the hell did he get the
37 who are the people that vote who are
the people that voted for him at 37. who
the hell voted did anybody here vote for
Biden
I'll tell you what if you did you don't
have the courage in this group to admit
it
all right what's the next one is there a
next one let's go put it up
general election Trump Biden where is
that let me see Missouri I love Missouri
we have a good candidate for the Senate
there and you have a great senator in
there right now too but you have a very
good Eric Eric Schmidt is I think great
he's going to win big he better win big
they all have to win
Donald Trump 53 Biden 37 plus 16 that's
pretty good Missouri Great plays Eric
Schmidt he's going to win and we have
these these polls are all like this and
these opposed I don't know who these
companies are these are natural polls I
think Trump polls would be better
actually
but these are Big up 16 in Missouri what
a great State anymore do you have any
more is this interesting it's sort of
interesting anymore
[Applause]
great senators in Oklahoma so you have
Donald Trump at 59 Joe Biden what a
shock Oklahoma would vote Trump that's
hard to that that's really a signal huh
the home is something very special I
love Oklahoma and they love my
standstill and energy and other things I
think I love that state but you have 77
districts Ronald Reagan has always had
they understand that in 2020 Trump got
65 percent in Oklahoma he's bragging
about these numbers these are worse
numbers than Trump's 2020 results in
Oklahoma he's like look
in Oklahoma I would do worse in 2024
than I did in 2020. see that's isn't
that a great thing a place called
Washington D.C
anyway that's sort of cool right those
polls just came out really quick I
figured I'd tell you so the fake news
when they give you their fake self but
those are I mean literally that poll is
Trump losing six points compared to
2020. I don't know what point he's
trying to make great polls Doug I think
you're going to see numbers that you're
going to be surprised at and Oz I think
you're going to see numbers and all of
our great congressmen many of whom are
here
and we're going to introduce in a second
to every citizen who is appalled by the
radical left lawlessness and Corruption
and they are corrupt this election is
your chance to make your voice heard
with your vote you can reject left-wing
Maniacs you can reject
left wing tyranny and proudly declare
that America will always remain a free
country we're not going to remain a free
country that when you see what's
happening with the FBI and with Justice
we're not going to remain a free country
now maybe things will happen that'll
free it up but I'll tell you we just we
we have to do it we want to do it at the
voter booth and you have your chance so
we can't blow this chance you could take
the five worst Presidents in American
history and put them together and they
would not have done the damage Joe Biden
has done to our nation in less than
Too Short do you think of it we're
talking about less than two years that
our nation is like destroyed we have a
little clip you know we bought these
beautiful
uh screens of course the fortune it
costs too much to rent them I said if
you rent them for three things I could
own them so I said let's buy them if you
don't mind so we put them and take a
look at this clip this is on Joe Biden
how would you say your mental focus is
it's focused
I said I think it's I I haven't look
let's get it ready to come back yeah I
mean I have an alternate video for you I
don't think Trump's the guy who should
be playing these clips
I love Donald Trump but no more dropped
by the drop boxes are just so bad no
more drop boxes Dickinson apologic and
cephe
hide that was about a guy named a rhino
named Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
real Beauty I had to give the American
people their voice back by building
something called truth truth essential
flaw and he voted for
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel right and he's doing
great I've had more investigations than
Jesse James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive
[Music]
what said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the bronze star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
but but it's not I mean for some reason
it's just not great anymore if you care
about law and Autos look Law and Order
in normal times roughly 40 percent of
fresh vegetables at about 40 percent
China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
you we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's ever seen
anything happen units of plasma for
plasma donate plasmid into failing New
York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children while our
parent of himself
no
body has to have parental consent and we
will totally oppose the Biden
Administration take this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements uh on Jewish
you've heard them very very tough
statements under all right so anyway
he's the last guy who should be playing
those those looping Clips anything like
it so much money we had it down to forty
dollars we had gasoline at a dollar
eighty seven a gallon today it hit eight
dollars in parts of California it's
going to hit you again no it didn't
because they're going to stop taking out
of these strategic reserves which we
largely filled up we filled it up and
now it's down to almost empty not
supposed to be used to get votes for an
election supposed to be used for
National Security
under my leadership and with the help of
Pennsylvania energy workers we had for
the first time American Energy
Independence and we were soon going to
be dominant we were going to be bigger
than Russia and Saudi Arabia combined
now Biden is begging and pleading with
OPEC but instead of increasing
Productions they actually cut it back
they said we're not going to increase
I'm sorry we're going to cut it back who
who would think that this is possible
for this country to be talked to that
way treat it that way under my
leadership we gave you the largest tax
cuts and regulation Cuts in American
history by contrast the radical democrat
congress passed one of the largest tax
hikes in American history under the
administration our wonderful
Administration we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world with
no inflation Biden and the democrat
congress created the worst inflation in
50 years
nine point one percent but it's much
higher than that it's not 9.1 I believe
it's double that and I hope you're not
counting on having turkey for
Thanksgiving because number one you
can't get a turkey and number two if you
do it will cost approximately three
times what you paid last year
so good luck on Thanksgiving
but if you buy ham that's going to be
doubled you'll make a much better deal
and Bacon's not too good either I think
bacon went up Ham on Thanksgiving is
that a thing country's in trouble I have
to tell you and please don't tune out
I don't even really know about doing an
entire turkey on Thanksgiving I would
almost rather do like a couple whole
chickens because it's 50 minutes and you
can get beautiful I mean it's just it's
perfect or even just do like turkey
breast only you know and then put them
anyway it doesn't matter turn to
Afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever had
we've never had anything like it
think of it leaving
85 billion dollars worth of the best
military equipment in the World Behind
and more importantly leaving American
citizens behind and having 13 of our
great people soldiers killed and many
wounded so horrifically they don't talk
about that no legs no arms your face
blown to Pieces nobody talks about that
I talk about that there was no reason we
didn't lose one soldier in 18 months in
Afghanistan I spoke to the head of the
Taliban
Abdul spoke to the head of the Taliban
and the Press went crazy why do you
speak to the head of the time is the
Abdul or Muhammad because that's the one
that are making those decisions and I
said to Abdul Abdul it's Abdul don't
kill any of our soldiers don't kill any
of our soldiers and then I said some
other things that I won't repeat here
but it was a strong conversation we
didn't lose one soldier in 18 months and
we were getting out of Afghanistan 21
years
spending a Fortune 50 billion dollars a
year
but we were getting out but we were
going to get out with strength and
respect strength we weren't going to
take our soldiers out first we're going
to take our soldiers out last and we're
going to keep Bagram that's a big Air
Force Base because it's one hour away
from China where they make their nuclear
weapons but we left in the dark of night
with the lights on we left the dogs too
by the way for those people that said no
we didn't they left the dogs
a lot of dog lovers they say what
happened to all the dogs they left them
but we we took this situation and I
don't think there's ever been a greater
humiliation but we didn't fire any of
the generals that were so incompetent or
any of the people involved in that
horrible decision to take our soldiers
out first
they were afraid of us they were afraid
of our f-16s now they own the f-16s we
gave them everything I think it's the
greatest humiliation they understand it
better than anybody that this country
has ever seen the election was rigged
and stolen and now our country is being
destroyed I ran twice I won twice it did
much better the second time than I did
the first getting really energetic and
millions of more votes the election was
rigged and stolen I ran twice I won
twice
any sitting president and the history of
our country by far and now in order to
make our country more successful and
safe and glorious
I'm just going to tell you I really
believe I'm not going to say it right
now but I'm telling you Uncle Sam said
no you are Uncle Sam just said no you
are going to say again
Uncle Sam you'll be very happy
what's going on
thank you
oh this is a thing where it happened at
a rally that some cute people in the
audience started singing the national
anthem when Trump mentioned Uncle Sam it
looks like it's what's happening again
right it is like Jonestown 2.0 look at
these people so
I miss you
very next neck very very very short
period of time
you're going to be so happy okay
going to be sorry
and one of the reasons I I don't want to
do that right now because I'd like to do
it but you know what and I really mean
this I want to have the focus tonight be
on Dr Oz and on Doug maustria Trump's
thinking about other people in his
decision not to announce his presidency
tonight
ah we believe that don't we the others
that are running but most of you guys
are in pretty good shape I'd say that
Kelly is in pretty good shape right what
are you leading by by 39 points or
something he's leading by about 39.
so I want the focus to be on them
absolutely all right now you can sit
down everybody
that was quite exciting very very soon
you're going to be surprised that you
guys want to see one more clip from Luke
Beasley on the ground in Pennsylvania he
just sent me a second clip we could look
at three days from now Pennsylvania has
the chance to elect an amazing Patriot
as your next Governor actually let's
wait question I know a man I got to know
I don't want to miss the actual
candidates doing their suck up routine
I got to know him and his incredible
wife very well she's incredible
he is a tough former army colonel he
took no Guff you weren't big on taking
Guff for you
for three decades he was a real great
Soldier highest level Doug is a fighter
and a warrior for the America First
agenda and for the people of this great
Commonwealth he is the only person in
this race standing between your family
and Pennsylvania being destroyed by
violent crime your crime is destroying
you here
and your guy is a disaster
your people your your Shapiro guy is a
disaster as the Attorney General he's
pretty good but you have soaring taxes
and left-wing Anarchy that's what's
happening on your streets all right okay
let's look real quick at the next clip
we we are on the ground in Pennsylvania
today
uh this one gets pretty weird from what
Luke tells me let's just see here
want to hear from Donald Trump tonight
make America great again and what has
made it not great what is made in our
grades what's going on right now open
borders High inflation uh everything
that's going on right now just
diametrically oppose the economy to
taxes it's diametically
diametically that's another beautiful
portmanteau it's diametrically
and medically it's the opposite of
Medical
diametically 1000 IRS agents I mean we
have all night I mean the moon will set
tomorrow by the time so like you said
there's so many issues less zero in on
one uh inflation are you saying you
blame Joe Biden for inflation well when
you sit there and you stop fossil fuels
and the country's running out of diesel
in 17 days and no trucks no boats no
play nothing's going to be moving yeah
you might want to open up fossil fuels I
think this is coming
I think it's coming from the Vatican the
vatican's meeting today we're world
leader uh oh the Vatican it's a Catholic
conspiracy
and at Mount Sinai Joe Biden is getting
his marching orders from the Jesuit oath
if you open Mount Sinai open up to
Jesuit and this might be a little crazy
to these people I don't really care
Google to Jesuit oath that when when Joe
Biden was elected president he opened up
on a with a Jesuit priest on a Jesuit
Bible we've had two Roman Catholic
presidents this country and Joe Biden
has taken orders just read the Jesuit
Joe biding I like that that explains so
much of everything wow so it's a
Catholic conspiracy is what it is that's
uh that that's really something huh it
torn up and brutalized by the radical
Democrat policies of the Socialists or
Communists left I say Communists left
now under Shapiro murders in
Philadelphia have sort and despite being
given special authority to fight crime
in Philadelphia
Shapiro this guy he's got a good line of
crap that's about it he's done nothing
this guy has done nothing
and the Press protects him look at those
people back there right is he gonna go
anti-semitic is he going to make rough
statements on Jewish about Josh Shapiro
is he trying to resist hey
take out this state during the 2020
riots Shapiro left your homes and
businesses at the mercy of rioters and
anarchists and arsonists it was a
disaster and he's going to do it again
he's not going to do a damn thing he's
weak and he's ineffective during coven
Shapiro sadistically used his office to
close your children's schools and to
force masks to be strapped around their
faces which really set him back look at
how it set him back
if Shapiro is elected your jobs will
disappear your property values will
crater in your communities will be taken
over by crime and by chaos
a vote for Josh Shapiro is a vote to
destroy Pennsylvania's future a vote for
Doug mastriano is a vote he can't even
pronounce mastriano correctly
um the people in the chat are picking up
you know we've seen this a lot it's
going to be a police state under the
Democrats who are defunding the police
Josh Shapiro is a communist dictator but
also extremely weak huh it's weird huh
oh yeah
this guy's dead welcome back to the
great state of Pennsylvania Mr President
dangerous
Pennsylvania loves you
we need you
he was such a great president that even
bloodladimir Putin behaved for four
years it's amazing absolutely fantastic
Pennsylvania three days away from
Victory we're gonna take back our state
restore freedom and Hope just so you
know this guy's going down this guy's
getting flushed he's down 11 to Shapiro
he has no CH like I know everybody's got
to vote this guy's gonna lose and he's
gonna say it was rigged I think it's a
thousand two thousand victims it's worse
than Afghanistan I mean it's a disaster
failure is not an option we have to win
the future for our children and our
freedom is at stake but I know in three
days there's going to be a new day in PA
I know you won't be you'll be you'll be
done
Mr President
when you're in charge we could afford
gasoline and heating our homes and so
Pennsylvania is going to stand in a gap
on day one of my Administration we're
going to drill and dig like never before
there will be no such Administration
this guy's gonna get crushed
on day one all masking and Jab
requirements will end forever in
Pennsylvania
you'll never be there
you choose
on day one woke is broke that's right
CRT is he talking about day one of Josh
Shapiro's Administration
we're going to defend our children this
graphic point of the schools will be out
of there yep that's a real problem
there's just porn in every school it's
crazy you can be able to choose the walk
is free people it's going to be amazing
we're blessed to be standing here in
this great state where our nation was
birthed in 1776 where the light of
Liberty was lit a new birth of freedom
in 1863. and Mr President we remember on
that dark day on the 9 11.
you showed your leadership skills in
that darkest time to give us hope in our
country Trump bragged that his Tower in
lower Manhattan was now the tallest
building that's what Trump did on 9 11.
you and your family for standing in a
gap for us it's incredible a sacrifice
you've gone through here
and so
we're looking for a new day in PA Mr
President just a couple minutes down the
road here Somerset County we're Flight
93 crashed and we remember Todd Beamer
what he said and Pennsylvania is going
to say that in three days Let's Roll
uh Doug mastriano is going to lose and
he will hopefully never be heard from
again but he is he's losing badly
very badly and he'll say it was rigged
but Josh Shapiro will be the next
Governor now the Federman Oz race is a
different story
all right
now
get out and vote for him don't forget
the money they poured into this race
against Doug is crazy it's crazy tens
and tens and tens of millions of dollars
and Doug has to do with the
old-fashioned way with good policy and
he's a great man he's a strong man get
out and vote for him you know it's
unfair you turn on television all you
see are these Shapiro commercials paid
for by Washington by the way
and it's a disgrace but you have to get
them in
and of equal importance a friend of mine
I've known him so long I was on a show
he examined me can you believe
and I liked him except that he had to
take that one little shot he said but if
he lost 20 pounds that would be
excellent so
so I never liked him as much as I should
but I got back to liking him really well
when I saw his policies and all of the
other things but you know he was a great
doctor I know people don't really
realize that they think of me with the
television stuff so listen folks the
latest polling out of Pennsylvania for
Oz fetterman is Oz ahead by
0.1 that is not a verbal glitch I'm not
Trump calling for the oranges of the
investigation or saying let's talk about
Kwame Vive camun and
Oz is winning by 0.1
fetterman can win
fetterman can win Federal and by the way
the way you get that 0.1 includes a
Trafalgar group poll and a Remington
research poll which are both overtly
right-wing push pullers okay
Oz can lose this but you gotta vote I
don't vote in Pennsylvania but if you do
you've got to vote Joe Biden socialist
spending spree and he'll fight runaway
inflation and he's a strong man he's a
strong guy and he's uh quick yeah listen
people saying don't believe the polls
don't believe the polls and what if you
believe fetterman's really winning well
you got to go and vote to make the polls
a reality if you believe fetterman's
losing then you got to vote to go help
him win either way you just got to go
and vote in those cameras and show I
just wish look at that you can't even
see the end of them and they never do it
they never do it
it's so sad to see that thank you
everybody as far as the eye can see over
there too you can't even say I wish I I
always hate I always hate us when we
give the presses prime location and then
we have people that have to stand behind
there's no press there no one cares the
cameras only have so much capability so
I don't know what the hell it is
but I wish he could turn you know I
never knew when I first started in 2015
and I go to these big rounds because the
rallies have always been big I think
they're bigger now than they've ever
been yours because people want to Hope
they want change and they want hope they
really believe it I think Uncle Sam I
think they're bigger than they ever were
but I used to Marvel
at the fact that I had these massive
crowds and the cameras would never show
them and I figured that the cameras are
you know hard and steel and they
couldn't make the turn the cameras are
made of steel
the cameras would bend like a pretzel
and it's
anything bad if there was somebody that
shouted something that was not so nice
the cameras would turn around in 15
different things and then and then they
said well that's not the reason they
refused to show the size of our crowds
and I don't understand why and it's
actually good for them I was very good
at getting good holders by the way I
still am
did you see where all these people that
don't like us they're dying I saw Jimmy
Kimmel said that his Show's practically
dead because somebody that likes Trump
will watch and guess what that turned
out to be a majority of the people the
show is dead and so the other ones
did Jimmy Kimmel say that on cable has
the number one evening show is that
possibly before
think of that I couldn't care less about
Jimmy Kimmel we do have to give our
respect to a man named
Sean Hannity because he's in there he's
been pictured
but all of them Tucker Laura they've
done great even if I don't like Fox so
much I tell you we have some they do
have some great people over there but Dr
Oz will vote to terminate Biden's open
borders Insanity restore the southern
border and stop the fentanyl that is
poor just pouring into our country and
positioning our youth Dr Oz will be
tough and strong and he's so smart and
he'll vote to support our police like
nobody that and I'm taking his raspberry
ketones just in case
yeah
what I did for them I took all of the
auxiliary and extra equipment that we
had all over the country the Wizards
auxiliary was tougher houses all over
the country I sent it out to police
forces all over the United States and
the Democrats were Furious they said you
shouldn't a lot of it was protective
equipment they said you shouldn't give
it because it looks too militaristic I
said no I'm trying to say policemen's
and women's lives but we gave billions
and billions of equipment that would
still be sitting there
growing dust
and of Oz will vote and very strongly to
keep violent criminals in jail Dr Oz
will become the first Pennsylvania
Governor to drink his own urine on
inauguration day somebody shoots
somebody through the head and by the
time the evening rolls around he's
already out on the streets again what
the hell is going on
I mean your guy is at a level that I
guess nobody we have a couple of them
but nobody's ever seen anything like it
a man kills somebody and he's out on the
streets within 24 hours
all of that will stop I know it's going
to stop with Doug and it's going to stop
with us and they'll get it to work
Pennsylvania desperately needs Dr Oz of
the U.S Senate he could very well be the
tie-breaking vote as I said and
he will be a type I think it could very
well be healthy you cannot let the state
be lost and by the way he is so much
better than the senator that he's
replacing I cannot tell you to me this
guy is like 10 times better than to me
to me was he didn't want to charge China
tariffs he didn't know why
but this is a man who's going to be an
unbelievable Senator you know Dr Oz is
running against somebody named John
fetterman he's become quite fabulous
by far the most extreme and unhinged
left-wing politician ever to run for
office in Pennsylvania and maybe in the
country that's not true by his own
admission John fetterman wants to
release one third of Pennsylvania's
prison population that's in the midst of
a crime wave you have a crime wave here
and he wants to release one-third but it
would be much more than that at his
ideal dream and he wants to abolish cash
bails no cash Bail no nothing fetterman
said that if he had one wish he would
wish to end life sentences without
parole for convicted murderers and
rapists he publicly bragged that his
goal is to get as many criminals out of
jail as he possibly can these are
killers these are killers and drug lords
these are rapists at the highest level
the most vicious rapists in the world he
wants him to get out as your Lieutenant
Governor fetterman supported releasing a
man who stabbed his girlfriend sends
mother to death with a pair of scissors
and a criminal who killed an innocent
man with a garden shears in a parking
garage and violently stabbed him again
and again and again
fetterman said he was happy to
get him released he wants him released
fetterman will mean death and despair
for every community in your Commonwealth
fetterman proudly supports deadly
Sanctuary cities and he signed a pledge
to Ben frackin for you energy people and
I'm a big energy person that's why I
believe we won Pennsylvania twice
we did much better by the way the second
time you know that in Pennsylvania too
not only in the election but in
Pennsylvania I don't think that's true
he wants to ruin your energy wealth
thereby raising your taxes you know
you're taking a lot of taxes because of
that energy not just jobs fetterman is
the single most dangerous Democrat
seeking to join Congress this year and
Dr Oz is the only one that can stop him
and he will stop him he is in there he
is working so hard he calls me he I'm
telling you this guy he wants to win and
you know I had a long talk with him
three days ago
he really wants to win because he wants
to help the people of the Commonwealth
I'm sure himself he wants to win because
he wants to help sad it out with him I
just said I said what is it and he
really and I'm pretty good at that stuff
he wants to help the people of
Pennsylvania Dr Oz please come up come
up please
you'd better suck up to Trump otherwise
he'll get bored
[Applause]
tomorrow morning when you awaken
I want you to contact 10 people do it a
church do it before the Steelers game
just find the time and here's that and
ask them have you thought about starting
your own home-based business the way
America is going
hold a second if they say yes
take their car keys away they should not
be driving in that condition
[Applause]
but most of them 70 percent will say no
and when they say no
tell them that I believe that we are the
land of opportunity
tell them that we are the Land of Plenty
and tell them that I will bring change
to Washington so they treat us the way
we deserve not praising Trump enough got
to praise God bless you wow
Oz never sucks up to Trump it's
interesting well I never not in the last
few a lot of Courage
gonna be a great Senator he'll be one of
the most respected senators
in our nation he'll be uh just do a
great job got to get them in we're also
joined tonight by some Warriors friends
of mine and I have to Senator I've been
thinking about drinking urine what do
you think only I was going to win a lot
of people were saying oh no no this was
before the Run said if you run you'll
get a win and you're going to win easily
his name is Congressman Mike Kelly
thank you Mike
thank you thank you Mike
another Warrior great guy a wonderful
man who loves the state congressman
Glenn GT Thompson listen I I know some
of you might be aware of this because I
did tweet about it Tulsi gabbard the
last true independent has now endorsed
Herschel Walker yeah how you doing Glenn
how is it good not a real opponent right
but get out and vote anyway you never
know right thank you Glenn
Dan muser Dan Dan you are fantastic I've
been my friend for a long time and
you've done a great job thank you very
much Dan appreciate it
Fred Keller and John Joyce where are
they John Fred great job these are
warriors I'll tell you they've been
there from from day one you've been with
me and we appreciate it fellas any other
congressmen here could you please stand
up stand up anybody else yes
but I don't like that particular
Congressman so I'm not going to
Pennsylvania state treasurer Stacy
Garrity
Stacy good job Stacy
good job
your next lieutenant governor Carrie Del
Rosso Terry calroso
that's a good question in the chat given
the time of today's rally that I have
dinner before or after the rally that's
a really good question what do people
think before after before after before I
add a small dinner early way too early
for me
and then I will I guess have like a
second small dinner after the rally yeah
so I'm doing fine we could go two more
hours here these are warriors these are
people that really love us all and you
know it would be great if you could let
all of those people back there start
drifting over here would be great give
them a good seat in front of that fake
news people are leaving so with us is a
fantastic woman
a woman of faith and a woman who's done
incredibly well in terms of helping
people Pastor Paula White Pastor Paula
White where is Pastor
where is Pastor Paula Pastor Paula thank
you very much
and I'm going to ask a man who's a great
man actually
one of the Great Men of our country
Kenneth Copeland to come up and say oh
my God
Kenneth Copeland's a lunatic
televangelist oh this is sick a prayer
oh my God
fantastic thank you very much this is
sick
I copied his suit oh my God look at this
there are things this guy's a freak this
great state of Pennsylvania
Liberty was born here
I've been accused of being a Christian
nationalist you are our first president
1789.
opened his Bible at the 17th chapter of
Genesis
where God made Covenant with Abraham is
he having a stroke and he read that
and he bowed his me
and he prayed
and he said
Obama will be our God
and we'll be your people
would you call him a Christian
nationalist
here's a Christian Patriot
[Music]
by Covenant this nation belongs to God
therefore voting is a sacred Trust
and if you don't vote
hush
for at least two years you have no
comment
I'm an old man I've lived through a lot
of presidents beginning with FDR
this is the only one I have ever seen
that wears red white and blue to the
office that's the reason I copied his
suit
and
a man that'll do what he says and keep
his campaign promises
I was in Jerusalem
where the American Embassy is on Donald
Trump Avenue in Jerusalem that's where
it belonged
that's not the real name of the street
um welcome to everybody rating us on
Twitch from Grand Master Benjamin
Feingold we have a sickening moment
where literal lunatic televangelist
Pastor Kenneth Copeland has been brought
out to say a prayer Jesus Christ of
Nazareth
whose we are and whom we serve
in a few days here
people will be going to the polls again
to cash vote in the greatest nation in
history
you're a perfect will will be done
and this nation will begin its change
and it will continue to do so and it
will continue under your leadership and
your guidance it will continue to change
and change and change until it is great
again
thank you sir we give you praise and
honor tonight
and I bow my knees
before the god of Heaven and Earth
to pray
as my President Washington prayed
still
you are our God
and we are still your people
thank you may God bless you come this
country may God bless you
Hallelujah the great state of
Pennsylvania we can stop this inflation
thing I come from the state of Texas
praise God and the president had us
energy independent again even exporting
all like we should be what a prayer
windmills won't do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what a prayer huh I mean hey I'm 86
years old those are not
those are not windmills they're wind
Chargers
my grandfather had one on top of the
house
and
in Texas I live on the lake there in
Fort Worth
all the electricity there
if the water comes out of the lake
and is fired by natural gas
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
Hallelujah
Mr President come up here
you know you'll probably have to take
this thing away from me but that's okay
I have a man
on the board of directors of our
ministry his name is Jim Thomas
this great professional football player
back in the day
he has drilled and is still drilling
some of the deepest gas wells in the
world he's drilling he was on Flashpoint
with Gene Bailey right
that's right and Gene asked him
how much untapped
Natural Gas Energy
do we have in the United States
without question he said we have a
enough natural gas in the United States
the noise to serve this country's needs
for 200 years
[Applause]
it's not that long not Pennsylvania
same thing
that's right
thank you
you're my president
oh my God thank you very much God bless
you good night thank you
good job did he just end the rally are
they like are they is everybody leaving
that would be great
oh no Trump's gonna say more that's too
bad
[Applause]
now they're doing the national anthem
wow this is crazy this this is it's a
it's an insane asylum it's an insane
they bring up Kenneth Copeland who says
crazy stuff and now they're randomly
singing the national anthem from the
crowd uh
meanwhile Obama's like hey let's try to
preserve democracy I don't know guys
[Applause]
yalkaida yeah I know I know
you're good
I think the people who just raided from
Benjamin Feingold are like get me the
hell out of here
[Applause]
they were so overcome with patriotic
fervor and zealotry by Kenneth
Copeland's speech about his lake house
that they just burst into the national
anthem spontaneously right
now
USA USA
USA USA
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much and thank you to
Kenneth 86. you look good you look good
with the help of everyone here today
over four incredible years we achieved
more for the people of Pennsylvania than
any Administration in history by far the
congressman know that we ended the
disaster known as NAFTA the worst trade
deal ever made and replaced it with
usmca Mexico Canada
and it was probably considered now the
best trade deal in fact so good that
they want to renegotiate it that's like
Boeing
a giant win for Pennsylvania workers
farmers and manufacturers as you all
know
we also made it even larger and
phenomenal trade deal with China and we
did the terrible deals with South Korea
Japan and other countries taking them
from really bad deals to really good and
even great deals we renegotiate a lot of
these horrible deals
I withdrew from the job killing
trans-pacific partnership which would
have put you out of business and I
placed stiff tariffs on foreign aluminum
and steel which kept your aluminum and
steel businesses thriving really doing
very well do you notice they haven't
taken the tariffs off because they say
if they do that's the end of the steel
industry in this country I withdrew from
the one-sided Paris climate Accord
canceled the falsely named clean power
plan was a nice name but it was a
disaster for our country and just as I
promised we put our miners back to work
our miners went back to work and I don't
know if you know what Germany now is
opening up coal mines all over their
country because their Green New Deal was
a disaster but Biden has resumed the war
on coal your call yesterday he declared
that we're going to be shutting down
coal plants Across America can you
believe this we should be off coal
unreliable wind and solar because it's a
fortune most expensive energy you could
have an outrageous slap in the face to
Pennsylvania coal country and I was the
one that closed the Russian Pipeline
remember I said nope we're closing the
Russian Pipeline
which no other president had the courage
to even talk about and then Biden
allowed them to go forward with it we
fought for Pennsylvania and we won for
Pennsylvanian with Republican victories
on Tuesday we will fight and win for
Pennsylvania once again I see people
dropping like flies if people need Mercy
bands the moderators can do it I I
understand if you have to leave this is
this is pretty sickening we can Mercy
ban people if uh if they need it
now we just now we lost the signal
thinkable five years ago we would get
critical race Theory out of our schools
out of our military and out of every
part of our federal state and local
governments
and at long last every parent in America
must be empowered to opt out of the
forced indoctrination in the classroom
and send their child to them no teacher
should ever be eligible to teach
transgender for their choice have to do
it school choice
and we will also keep men out of women's
sports if that's okay with you right
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without parental consent
it's not what they want they want to do
it without parental consent we're not
going to let that happen Oz
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican Congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to re we
have to restore Free Speech because we
don't have free speech and it's because
of them everyone go out and sign up now
by the way for truth social which is
doing incredible is a hell of a lot
better than Twitter truth and by the way
if you think it's easy to look at a
teleprompter when it's got a 40 mile an
hour wind
I feel like a drunken salad these things
are waving all over
do I even need to ask whether he's going
to do the Q Anon music here tonight
Tuckers are going back and forth I'm not
a drinker so I don't know what it is to
be drunk but I think this would be it
I'm going back
now we're we're winging it tonight a
little bit I hope everyone's enjoying it
it's a strong wind but it's a beautiful
filmed it's not too cold
the only thing worse is when you have to
do that and it's also freezing
[Applause]
and everywhere the Republican Party
critical election Integrity reforms
including Universal voter ID who
wouldn't want that
sent you who wouldn't want it
so they fight us on voter ID they fight
us on a thing called citizenship
confirmation so they don't want to have
us any confirmation that a person's a
citizen you know why because they want
to cheat that's why that's why they
don't want voter ID actually 84 percent
of Democrats want voter ID but the
leaders don't want it because they want
to cheat no more fake drop boxes no
private money pouring into local
election offices and ultimately we need
same-day voting with only paper ballots
that's what we need motorizing
we're just three days that's an
interesting question in the chat would I
have dinner with Trump I would gladly
have dinner with Trump but it seems like
the food might be really weird like
assuming it's not fast food Trump seems
like the type of guy who wrote likes
really old-fashioned stuff like you go
oh give me a steak well done with mashed
potatoes you know and gravy or something
like that like hey hey how about we have
like uh you know what about like a tom
yum soup and it'd be like no that's the
from China and it's like no it has
nothing to do with China what are you
talking about
Jesus I love this guy he says bring him
out I'm ready this is the year we're
going to take back the house we're going
to take back the Senate and we're going
to take back America we're going to take
it back
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our magnificent oh
it's so beautiful white house we're
going to take it back and you're going
to be hearing about it very soon very
very very soon
together we will fight for more jobs for
Pennsylvania families fair trade to
Pennsylvania workers some people are
running out look at that one guy was
just sprinting out stamped with that
beautiful beautiful phrase made in the
USA right Mike
we will shut down Biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in Mexico remember I got that approved
by a great gentleman
president of Mexico is a great man he's
a great gentleman happens to be a
socialist but he can't have everything
right
but we got that
I said to the representatives of Mexico
you gotta have them remain in Mexico
they didn't know what I was talking
about they said why would we do that
because you have to do it everyone said
you'll never get that approved I said
yeah we'll get it approved you have to
do it and also we want 28 000 Mexican
soldiers to guard our border they said
we're not going to do that of course
we're not going to do that the state
department though he already told this
story tonight like I know he tells it at
every rally
he's already told it tonight 100 will
get it 100 percent then the top person
in Mexico came in and he saw me and he
smiled when I said and he said they've
been asking for this for 20 years I said
yes you are 100 he said what do you mean
he said 100 here's the story it was a
Thursday afternoon and I said on Monday
morning at nine o'clock we're putting a
25 tariff on everything that Mexico
sells to the United States including the
32 percent of our automobile practice
and Manufacturing that they they stole
you know they have 32 percent of the
cars that were made here had moved down
to Mexico we stopped that
but I said you're going to put a
terraform of 25 every car that comes in
every product that comes in so I'd like
to have five minutes may have five
minutes yes you may came back he said
sir we'd love to have 28 000 soldiers
guarding your border
so we would love to I'm starting to
wonder whether somehow the video looped
back to the beginning because he just
told this story 45 minutes ago such
wonderful people sir they agreed to
every one of ten requests and then Biden
came in and gave them all up for nothing
we don't understand it there's something
going on we don't understand it but we
had the safest border we will strengthen
the Patriots of ice and Border Patrol
Brandon Judd what a great gentleman he
is to Tom Holmen Brandon Judd they have
great people believable people
Mark Morgan
and we will again in Catch and Release
we will end chain migration we will end
the Visa Lottery these are things you
don't have to know too much about them
but trust me they're bad
and we will end illegal immigration once
and for all we did most of it most of
those things we had and then they gave
them up so not that much to do then I
guess we will stop the crime wave in
democrat-run cities we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect they deserve they're incredible
and we will not take legal protection
away from our police they want our
police
to go out and get
legal representation should they have a
problem no we will represent our police
if they have problems we will restore
Law and Order In America we will hold
China accountable we care about leasing
of the powers upon the world
the damage is
beyond anything beyond comprehension we
will abolish all coveted mandates and
lockdowns and rehire every patient are
there any lockdowns from the military
with an apology and back pain
what lockdowns are there we will defend
our constitution we will defend the
Second Amendment and we will proudly
uphold the judeo-christian values and
principles of our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor
their history and to always respect our
Great American flag here comes the Q
music right
in conclusion
our Mega movement make America great
again we have to explain that to Biden
when he hits Maga say no no no you don't
understand the meaning Maga is make
America great again I watched him the
other day say we must stop America first
I said that's an awfully bad you know
what you should say is we got to stop
Trump policies stop Trump policy but you
can't say stop America First you can't
say we will stop making America great
again it doesn't work I don't think what
do you think in conclusion I did not
read the book about which this
presentation was based are the greatest
political movement in the history of our
country together we are standing up
against some of the most menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents our people have ever seen
we've never seen anything like what's
going on today
despite great outside Danger
our biggest threat Remains the sick
Sinister and evil people from within our
country I really believe it
but no matter how big or powerful the
corrupt radical left Democrats that we
are fighting against may be you must
never forget this nation does not belong
to them Trump's been speaking about an
hour and 37 minutes
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your
god-given right
from Allentown to Johnstown
from Harrisburg to Pittsburgh and from
Philadelphia to Latrobe you know what
Latrobe is the trobe I love Latrobe it's
the home of the great Arnold Palmer
who's looking down now
Arnold Palmer he was one of the greats
one of the Great Men
much more than a great golfer he was a
great man and he led Latrell
Pennsylvania he told me I said Arnold
you can be anywhere in the world why do
you stay in Latrobe he said because I
love the people of Latrobe I love this
whole thing he bought the course as a
young man when he made money his father
worked as a laborer
at the course and Arnold won the U.S
amateur he was a great player in college
he used to practice with his father the
father would have to borrow members
clubs because they couldn't afford to
buy Arnold a club think of that oh God
and Arnold tells the story people start
crying when they hear it his father was
great but he was a very strong man he
was a laborer he was a sod carry he
could carry more sod than any other man
and he ended up teaching his boy how to
play with other people's clubs they
couldn't get a club they couldn't afford
one Club
so that's the members and that let them
use the club late at night
and then all became a great golfer and
he won the U.S amateur and then he
turned Pro and from day one he made
money and he saved a little bit of up
after three or four tournaments he
already had good money
and he bought the course and he made his
father the superintendent from labor to
superintendent I don't know if you know
this he's like a great story
became a very rich man Arnold very very
rich the story is someone who was poor
ended up making a lot of money in
professional sports okay great story
thanks Mark McCormick should I tell the
story or not no no they're not going to
leave right please don't you're not
going to leave everybody wants to hear
this so IMG
is one of the big big companies in
Hollywood it's a big agency the biggest
I guess or just about but very powerful
and Mark McCormick started it
but he was playing for a certain college
and Arnold went to Wake Forest and he
was the number one player in the team
obviously you know he's not the number
two or three or four and then he ends up
being the best right we're screwed but
he was the number one player for Wake
Forest and Mark McCormick was a smart
guy but he wanted to be did you people
know this Hershey is a chocolate bar but
also a place in Pennsylvania
fake news media won't tell you that
privilege who's the best player on his
team
a college and then he had the privilege
of oh sorry it's chocolate bar yeah I
know and Arnold Palmer was obviously
number one so he got the chance to play
Arnold Palmer who he had heard about
Arnold had won the U.S amateur
so they start off
and around the ninth hole somebody
called over tomorrow how are you playing
it's the best I've ever played how are
you doing I'm sixth down
he was six down before the ninth hole
and he realized then that he could never
be a great player because Arnold Palmer
was so much better he was Stronger
longer he was a better chipper and
Potter he was better at everything
so Mark McCormick being a very smart guy
said Arnold you're really incredible
what I'd like to do is I'd like to
represent you as your agent I'd like to
start a company called IMG and I'd like
to represent you as a way with words
Obama was the first person represented
did you know that Uncle Sam by IMG
and it became a Powerhouse it became an
absolute Powerhouse and Arnold owned
actually 50 of it and over the years
he'd sell it it wasn't his thing he
loved golf so much but he made a fortune
he bought television networks he bought
a lot of things but Arnold Palmer became
a very good friend of mine in his latter
years and I got to play golf with Arnold
when he was quite a bit older he was uh
about 83 or 84. we have reached the 100
minute Mark in the speech
I will tell you and
actually wait no it's probably even
longer than now that I think about it
and I might be three yards longer but
you know he was 83 84 years old don't
get carried away
and I looked at Arnold and I said Arnold
let me ask you a question do you think
40 50 years ago I was longer than you
like I am now he looked at me this is
before vice president he said what let
me tell you something you weren't even
close in fact
did he say was he was he longer what the
hell is he talking about man he's gonna
represent you long and hard yeah he
looked at me and he said in fact I could
build a giant Walmart in between our two
balls
that wasn't very nice right
but Arnold was great he was a great man
he was a great man and Beyond a golfer
he was a great man and he came from
Latrobe Pennsylvania so I have a very
warm spot for Latrobe because he was a
friend of mine
incredible guy I could tell you so many
Arnold series but I thought that was
that's self-deprecating right I hate to
admit it but it's so funny Arnold always
fun I said I agree with you
we stand on the shoulders of American
legends who poured out their Blood Sweat
and Tears for our rights and for our
freedom Pennsylvania is where our
founding fathers declared American
independence think of the importance of
this state what you're going to be
representing and what you're going to be
represented think of it think of it
it's where the Army weathered a brutal
winter at Valley Forge where General
George Washington LED his men on a
daring Mission across the Delaware
and where our Union well our whole thing
we had it all wrapped always saved
entire thing the immortal Heroes at
Gettysburg think of Gettysburg
Gettysburg Pennsylvania guys I don't
know that I can do this two more nights
in a row
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania is by the way
one of the most beautiful sights you've
ever seen But the site of one of the
most vicious battles anyone has ever
seen or partaken in
and this is the state where generations
of tough strong Pennsylvania miners they
want to take away your jobs Factory
workers steel workers and energy workers
Forge the greatest nation in the history
of the world
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you here it is
it's so sad at least tomorrow we do have
the Bernie rally yeah no that's that'll
be good because we are now a nation in
Decline
it's no reason for this
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years I love how people
think I'm adding this music you know
like if I was adding music you know the
way I would do it
like this is actually part of the rally
likewise we are a nation that has the
highest energy costs in its history we
are no longer energy independent or
energy dominant as we were just two
short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
Venezuela Saudi Arabia and many others
for oil please please please help us Joe
Biden says
that we have more liquid gold right
under our feet
than any other country we are a nation
that is consumed by the radical left
screen new deal yet everyone knows that
the green New Deal will lead to our
destruction
[Music]
we are a nation whose leaders are
demanding all electric cars while
keeping the momentum going s Prez
dumping in a hundred subscriptions that
is absolutely stunning and a dystopian
moment in the rally the amount of
[Music]
Gilly
vagina
you're a nation that ended oil
exploration and production in the United
States just as
the price of oil reached an all-time
high
the highest it's ever been
what other country would do such a thing
we are a nation that surrendered in
Afghanistan leaving behind dead soldiers
American citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
in the world
and we are a nation that allowed Russia
to devastate a country Ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse it would never have
happened with me as your
commander-in-chief
and for four straight years it didn't
happen
and China with Taiwan is next
we are a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation
that won't allow bad election-changing
facts to be presented
about Donald Trump to lie and to say it
was fact and pays a man two hundred
thousand dollars to get Trump
where Hunter Biden's laptop from hell
was Russian disinformation and the FBI
knew it wasn't and a department of
justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we have a man who is
the worst president in the history of
our country who is cognitively impaired
and in no condition to no condition and
is now casually talking about nuclear
war with Russia which would be World War
III and far more devastating than any of
the previous Wars because of the
weaponry
that no one even wants to talk about
and we are a nation that no love it's
like the the real sad song would be
something like this
[Music]
we're a country where tens of millions
of imbeciles were tricked into voting
for me
and even though I obviously lost
I convinced them I won
and then they showed up at the Capitol
and committed acts of property crime
violence
and attacked our police
and then when they got arrested
they said it was antifa
and black lives matter
and even though I obviously don't care
about them and only wanted them for
their votes and money
they're so stupid that if I announce I'm
running again in 2024
they will vote for me again
because I will trick them with the exact
same lies I used
in 2016.
and 2020. that's like the real speech
you know what I mean not about like I
got I had to wait for my flight freedom
and faith we are a nation whose economy
is collapsing into a cesspool of ruin
whose supply chain these supplies our
beautiful supply chain is broken
and stores are not it's a pie chain
whose deliveries are not coming and
whose educational system is ranked at
the bottom of each and every list we are
a nation where large packs of sadistic
criminals and thieves
are going into stores and openly robbing
them beating up and killing workers
and killing the customers and leaving
with arm loads of goods but with no
retribution we're the authority of our I
just noticed by the way we just set a
record with a level 11 hype train on our
channel on Twitch it's Bonkers what's
happening we destroyed for the mere
mention of the words law enforcement
we are a nation where Fentanyl and all
other forms of illegal drugs are easier
to get than formula for our beautiful
little babies
a nation whose once revered airports are
a dirty crowded mess you sit and wait
for hours and then they are notified
that the plane won't leave and they have
no idea when they will we're ticket
price how about
[Music]
they told me not to look directly at the
eclipse
but I did because I didn't listen and
even if I had I don't really understand
what people say to me
willpower and its strength we are a
nation that has lost its way but we are
not going to allow this horror to
continue Hara two years ago we were a
great nation and we will soon be a great
nation again
foreign
it was the hard-working Patriots like
you who built this country and is the
hard-working Patriots like you who are
going to save our country we will stand
up to the radical left Democrats and the
dangerous and unpatriotic rhinos
and we will fight for America like no
one has ever fought before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet there is
no Victory we cannot have
we will not Bend we will not break we
will not yield we will never give in we
will never give up and we will never
ever ever ever back down
as long as we are confident United and
loyal to the cause
the tyrants we are fighting do not stand
even a chance
because we are Americans and Americans
kneel to God and to God Alone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the silent majority is back
and stronger than ever before
my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we are on together has only just
begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness for our country again we are
one movement one people one family and
one glorious nation under God
so with the help of everyone here today
at the citizens all across our land we
will make America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again and we
will make America great again thank you
everybody God bless you God bless you
thank you
[Applause]
it is finally over
Dear God
starting a half hour late and ranting
and raving for two hours including
telling some of the same stories
multiple times
showing a clip compilation of Biden
saying things incorrectly bringing up
lunatic Christian televangelist hate
preacher Kenneth Copeland
and playing Q Anon music while bemoaning
airports
Trump rally here and he's doing it again
tomorrow and Monday ladies and gentlemen
folks I don't know if I can do it we
have this goal of a thousand members we
made it to what is it what does that say
675 uh
which is a cumulative goal I I don't
know that I can do it I don't know I
mean it's it's
deranged and delusional and unhinged and
whacked and the saddest part of it are
the people who sit there and they go
that was great this guy should be
president
this guy should be president I know
people are saying we all have to do it
tomorrow tomorrow we've got Bernie and
then the Trump rally for Marco Rubio so
maybe Bernie will be a bit of a pallet
cleanser or an alternative it's it's
just completely crazy listen folks
before you leave if you're watching on
Twitch just follow my channel because
we're doing this every day and then
we'll have live election results on
Tuesday just fall it costs you nothing
okay before you leave if you're watching
on YouTube hit the Subscribe button it's
completely free we're trying to get to 2
million YouTube subscribers there's like
over three million people who watch our
Channel but don't subscribe just before
oh look at these numbers
look at this
wow all right well listen on your way
out just hit that subscribe button we're
doing it tomorrow and we're gonna go to
Monday and then we're gonna go to
Tuesday and it's gonna be it's gonna be
a whole thing these are very very strong
numbers no these are absolutely very
strong numbers also thanks to error and
Patsy's for the twitch Prime
subscriptions the goal is a thousand by
Tuesday and who knows maybe we'll be
able to get there sooner thank you
everybody who watched it was really
brutal I mean it it is an accomplishment
to even make it through one of these
rallies and we've got
four and five days
it's it's crazy it's crazy so I'm gonna
go uh have dinner I've got a beautiful
Butternut butter knot butternut squash
lasagna
absolutely delightful
tremendous Greek salad
uh Butternut yeah exactly butter yes or
Butternut you know either way
um we will see everybody tomorrow and
it's vile and it's sickening and uh we
may be just at the very beginning of
this horrible horrible period in
American history
starting on Tuesday sad to say it all
right see everybody very soon thank you
anyway
the drop boxes are just so bad no more
drop boxes Dickinson hologic and cephe
cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth Central
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've been